foreign
software development week from Simply
learn it's day two of software
development today we will be discussing
algorithms in data structures in case if
you missed out on day one where we
discussed the major fundamentals and
foundations of software development the
data structures then please feel free to
check out the cards above or made also
leave a link in the description box
below to all our videos or playlists
coming into the topic algorithms happen
to be the brains of any software program
you develop it happens to be a
programmer's baby steps to devise a
solution to the problem in a
step-by-step manner algorithms are the
main logical backbone of any software
development for example consider maps
for navigation that you use on your
smart devices
we use several algorithms like diastras
algorithm breadth first search depth
first search and many more to find the
shortest and most feasible path to
travel from source to the destination we
have just scratched the surface and
there's a whole mountain of algorithms
we'll learn all of those in detail with
practical implementation and detail so
stay tuned to us now over to our experts
let's get started
so we will begin this data structure
part 2 from where we left the data
structures part one that is trees and
data structures so followed by trees in
data structures we will be learning the
three traversal in data structures then
we will go through binary trees binary
search trees and then we will enter
recursion and after finishing recursion
we will begin with AVL trees then we
will continue with B trees and B plus
trees
followed by B plus trees we have the
Sorting algorithms so we will begin with
bubble sort then we will go through
insertion sort then we have selection
sort followed by that we have Heap Sort
then the merge sort quick sort bucket
sort and Counting sort algorithms moving
ahead we have the Radix sort followed by
the Sorting algorithms we enter in two
graphs and after learning the
fundamentals and some examples in graphs
we will continue with Crystal's
algorithm then the back tracking
algorithm then we have the spanning
phrase understanding the spanning trees
we will go through some breadth first
search and depth first search algorithms
which are used for exploring the nodes
and trees then we have shell sort then
the greedy algorithm and finally we have
the prince algorithm
so I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now without any further Ado let's
get started with the first concept in
the data structures part 2 that is trees
what is a tree data structure
so what exactly is that 3data structure
the tree is a non-linear data structure
that consists of nodes and is connected
by edges I know it's a little difficult
to understand just by the definition so
let me show you the pictorial
representation as you can see we have
the elements that is 10 20 30 40 50 60
and 70 and all these are stored in the
tree data structure they are stored in a
non-linear structure if we had used
Aries it would have been in a linear
consecutive way where 10 starts first
and 70 ends at the last position
now in the next section we will discuss
why we had made to a switch to the three
data structure when we already had a
linear data structure that is array
now the next topic that is why we need
3D structure
so there are many reasons why we have
switched into three data structure and
one of the reason is a linear data
structure always stores the elements in
a sequential form that is one after the
other and in operations to be performed
in linear data structure the time
complexity increases as the data size
increases you can see here that as
discussed before the elements are stored
in a linear form that is done at the
first place and 70 at the last place
imagine you wanted to access the element
70 then using the traversal you had to
start from the first position that is 10
20 30 40 and slowly at the end is 70. so
accessing that particular element is
really time consuming we are facing this
just for 70 elements imagine if we had
700 elements right so that is exactly
why we had made a switch to three data
structure and using trade data structure
we have many advantages as the tree data
structure is completely non-linear and
it allows easier access and quicker
access of the data elements how is that
possible we will look into it into the
next segment where we will discuss about
the traversal of trees
now before we understand their traversal
of trees we should understand another
important topic that has the
terminologies of tree
so the first one is the node node is the
entity that contains the keys and
pointer towards child nodes
so here you can see that the elements a
b c d e f and g are the elements so each
and every element or the blue dot is
called as a node and the blue dots here
are
one two three four five six and seven so
we have seven blue dots so we have seven
elements here so you can see the line
between each elements right so this
particular line is called H now we'll
discuss about the H in the next part
so the connecting links between any two
nodes are called as edges so we
discussed about the nodes right where
the element is stored the blue dots are
the nodes and the lines connecting
between the elements or notes is called
as the edge
so out of all the nodes this first node
that is the element a is called as the
root node in a tree data structure so
indirectly root node is also called as
the parent node of all the nodes now we
will understand what are parent nodes
and children nodes
so in a tree data structure the node
that is the node's predecessor is called
as parent node so here we have discussed
that a or the root node is the parent of
all nodes so for a b and c nodes are
children nodes and for B and C nodes a
happens to be the parent node similarly
D and E are the children nodes of B and
F and J are children nodes of c and the
notes d and e have b as a parent node
and the nodes F and J have C as the
parent node now followed by that
we will understand The Descendant node
so as discussed before The Descendant
node is the node that comes after the
parent node here the B and C are the
descendants of a and d and a are
descendants of p and similarly f and g
are The Descendants or children of the
node C
so in a tree data structure the node
which does not have any child is called
as the leaf node now at the end we have
d e f and g so these particular nodes do
not have any children nodes like B and C
so these particular four nodes which do
not have any children are called as the
leaf nodes
in a tree data structure the node with
at least one child node is called as the
internal node
so here the internal nodes are p and C
which have at least one child
in a tree the total number of children
of a node are called as the degree of
that node so in this particular diagram
the degree of root node is 2 because it
has two child nodes and the degree of p
is2 as it has two child modes similarly
the degree of CS2 because it has two
child nodes but when it comes to d e f
and g the degree is zero because they do
not have any child nodes
in a treated structure the root node is
said to be at level 0 and the children
of the root node are said to be at level
1 and the children notes of the level 1
are at level 2. so to understand this
let's go through the diagram as you can
see this particular root node is called
as level zero and followed by that we
have the children nodes of a that is PNC
and that level is called as level one
and followed by that we have level two
and if this tree goes forward the levels
also increase accordingly
now in a tree data structure the total
number of edges from a leaf node to the
particular node is the longest per and
this particular path is called as the
height of that node
now here we have our general tree data
structure and here you can see the
height of node a S2
and the height of node B and C together
is at 1 and the height of the last Leaf
notes happens to be zero
next in the tree data structure the
total number of edges from the root node
to a particular node is called as the
depth of that node now in this
particular three data structure the
depth of the root node is zero and the
depth of B and C to
1 because the number of edges connecting
to the node a from B is just one and
similarly the number of edges connecting
the node C from a is just one so the
depth of both b and c is 1. now if we
consider the last Leaf nodes then the
depth is 2 because if you see G is
connected to a using two different edges
similarly f is connected to a using two
different edges and E and D also have
two nodes to connect to a so the depth
is 2. now in the next segment we will
understand the tree node
so the tree data structure has data part
and references to its left and right
child node in the three data structure
so here you can see this is the node and
the node has three segments that is data
element and the references towards left
the child and the references to its
right child
now there are four different types of
trees the first one is the binary tree
followed by that we have the binary
search tree then we have AVL tree and
finally we have the B tree let us
discuss H1 of 10. the first one is the
binary tree a binary tree is a tree data
structure in which each parent node at
most has two children
so in this particular tree we'll have at
most two children that means it might
have one or more than one but not more
than two children per node
moving ahead we have the binary search
tree so a binary search tree or a BST is
a tree data structure in which each node
has a maximum of two children all nodes
of the left subtree are less than the
right node all nodes on the right
subtree are more than the root node so
here you can see the image or the GIF
which represents the image of a binary
search tree so here all the nodes of the
left subtree are less than the root node
and all the nodes of the right subtree
are more than the root node the next
type of the tree is the AVL tree the AVL
tree got its name after inventory
Georgie Adelson welsky and Landis
avl3 is the self-balancing tree in which
each node maintains a balanced factor
most value is either 1 0 or -1
balance factor is equals to height of
the left subtree minus height of the
right subtree or height of the right
subtree minus height of the left subtree
so in this particular image you can
identify it as an AVL tree and now the
last type of tree that is the B tree B
tree is a special kind of self-balancing
search tree in which each node can
contain more than one key and can have
more than two children B tree is also
known as the height balanced m-ray tree
now in this particular GIF we can see
how a battery looks like
now followed by this we will discuss the
tree traversal
so traversing a tree helps to visit
required note in the tree to perform
specific operations tree traversal can
be performed in three different ways the
first one is the pre-order traversal
where we visit the node
and visit all the node from the left
side then visit all the nodes from the
right side so this particular GIF is an
example for pre-order traversal where we
visit all the left side nodes first then
we visit the right side nodes now we
will move ahead into the next type of
traversal
that is the in order traversal first we
visit all the nodes from the left side
then we visit the root node and then
represent all the nodes from the right
side so this particular GIF will be an
example for the in order traversal where
we visit all the left side nodes then we
visit the root node and followed by that
we will visit the right side in nodes
and the last type of traversal is the
post order traversal Weber visit all the
nodes from the left side first then we
visit all the nodes from the right side
and finally visit the root node so this
particular image on the right side is an
example for post order traversal now
before we get into learning the
applications of trees we will try to
execute one example based on the post
order pre-order and in order traversals
entry data structure
so you can see that we have an example
on my screen right now so here we have
the node structure then we have the in
order travel cell function followed by
that we have the pre-order traversal
function and finally we have the post
order traversal function now let's
quickly run this program and see the
output and don't worry about the code
this particular code document will be
attached in the description box below
and you can have access to it
now we have the Run option over here and
the program got successfully executed uh
you can ignore this warning and here we
have the in order traversal of the tree
and the first output then we have the
pre-order traversal of the tree and
finally we have the post order traversal
of the tree now let's discuss the last
part where we will learn the application
of trees
so the application of trees are as
follows binary search trees are used to
quickly check whether an element is
present in the set or not then we have
the most popular database usage of B3
which is a variant of tree data
structure then we have the modified
version of trees called as Trice which
is used in the router to store routing
information and finally the compiler
uses a syntax tree to validate the
syntax of every program you write what
is tree traversal in data structure
tree traversal is a process of visiting
each and every node in a tree data
structure
so right here on my screen we have a
tree with different nodes that is a b c
d and e
so here we will be visiting all the
nodes one after the other using the
three traversal methods
now that we have a brief understanding
of what exactly is a tree traversal
process let's get into the next topic of
our discussion for today that is the
data structure used for free traversal
in a tree data structure there are
primarily two data structures utilized
for tree traversal the first one is the
start data structure and the second one
is the Q data structure a stack is a
linear data structure that operates on
the last end first out lifo principle
there is only one pointer in the stack
that is the top pointer which points to
the Stack's topmost element only the top
of the stack is used for insertion and
deletion now the next one is the queue a
q unlike stocks as open on both the ends
the one end is always open and used only
for input and the other is only used for
deletion or elimination the principle
followed in Q is first in first out or
fifo approach
followed by that we will look into the
different types of free traversals in
data structure tree traversal can be
done in the following ways the first one
is breath first search and the second
one is the death first search
first let us have a look at the breadth
first search algorithm or breadth first
search traversal we follow level order
traversal in breadth first search
breadth first search traverses notes by
level instead of subfreeze first we
visit the root node followed by the root
node we visit the left subtree of the
tree Then followed by the left subtree
we finished the right subtree of the
entire tree
after that we go until the leaf nodes of
the entire tree is found the second one
is the depth first search in depth first
search we Traverse three data structure
in three ways that is pre-order
traversal in order traversal and post
order traversal let us take a look at
how these traverses are carried out
first let us discuss the pre-order
traversal we Traverse the root node
first in the pre-order traversal then we
Traverse through the left subtree and
finally we Traverse through the right
subtree
then there is in order traversal in
order traversal involves traversing of
the left subtree first followed by that
we enter the root node and then we visit
the right subfree lastly we have the
post order traversal so post order
traversal involves traversing of left
subtree first then the right subtree and
finally we visit the root node
now next we will have a look at some of
the important applications of free
traversal in data structure
so we use tree traversal in data
structures to build a prefix expression
or polish notation from expression trees
then utilize the pre-order traversal and
then Traverse the expression Tree in a
pre-orderly manner
a binary trees post-fix representation
or reverse polish notation can be
generated using post order traversal
because it returns values from the
underlying set in order according to the
comparator setting up the binary search
tree in order traversal is often
employed on binary search trees
a complete binary tree can be deleted or
released when deleting or phrasing nodes
and values in the post order traversal
now next we will see an example based on
tree traversal in data structures
so on my screen we have an example for
tree traversal in data structure to
begin we have included the enum or
user-specified data type traversal it
mostly used to give integral constant
names which make a programmer easier to
comprehend and maintain
we defined three variables in the E num
data type that is free order in order
and post order traversal we can Define
the type that can take one of the two
values by using the type Def and enum
keywords we have a traversal data type
with trap variable and a node data type
with node variable then we Define the
node using the data structure type as
struct node we declare one variable X
and two nodes as a left and a right
notes respectively in this node section
we then attempted to create node using
the create node function passing the
root node as an argument in this code we
use a malloc function to create a node
assign data to X and null to both the
right and left nodes before returning to
the root node
if node T is not equal to null we simply
return it otherwise we will use the
release tree function to release the
left and right nodes and if neither is a
root node then we will use the free
function to release the node T which
will behave as the root node then we
Define the display tree function which
takes the Trap variable and the root
node as parameters
there is a condition in this function
that is if the root node is not null we
will return the root node then using the
switch case scenario we attempted to
Traverse the tree using all three types
of traversals we utilize a Trav variable
in the switch function so if any of the
in order pre-order or post order
variables match the Trap variable the
traversal will be executed then we
created a tree using the create tree
function which takes a data variable as
input in the create tree function we
used a malloc function to create the
root node and we first assigned a null
to the left and right nodes as well as
the data to the variable X before
returning to the root node
we first Traverse the root node then the
left subtree and finally the right
subtree in the pre-order traversal case
in order traversal case we first
Traverse the left subtree then the root
node and finally the right subtree and
in the post order traversal case we
Traverse the left subtree then the right
subtree and finally Traverse through the
root node and finally we exit the
display tree function and moved on to
the main function we assign the values 5
as the root node then 10 20 and 30 as
the left notes and similarly 15 25 and
35 as the right nodes and then we call
the three three traversals that is
pre-order in order and post order to
Traverse the tree and finally we release
the root mode now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that the output has been displayed on my
screen so the pre-order traversal is 5
10 20 25 15 30 and 35.
followed by the pre-order traversal we
have the in order traversal that is 20
10 25 5 30 15 and 35 and finally we have
the post order traversal that is 20 25
10 30 35 15 and 5.
and with that let me give you a simple
question
so what is the pre-order and post order
traversal of this binary search tree so
the elements are one two three four five
six and seven you need to find out the
pre-order and post order traversal of
this binary tree and you can let us know
the answer in the comment sections below
what exactly is a binary tree
so it is a treated structure in which
each node can have at most two child
nodes these nodes are referred to as
left child node and right child node
next let's discuss about some terms
related to binary tree
first up unknown a node consists of data
and a link towards both child nodes next
the root load root note is the first
node of the tree next Leaf nodes
these are the notes which has no child
next parent node apart from the root
node any node which has at least one
child is called as parent to that child
node next up a child node any node with
a parent is called as a child node
next up is the internal node any node
with a child and a parent has called as
an internal node next up is the height
of the binary tree the longest path from
the root to any Leaf node is called as
the height of the binary tree next up is
the depth of the binary tree the depth
of the node is the total number of edges
from the root load to the Target node or
the last child node
now let's try to implement the binary
tree in the code editor
as you can see now we are on the code
editor and the code on my screen is an
example for binary tree now here you can
see that we have created a structure of
a node followed by that we have a
function where we will print the tree
and this is our main function
now don't worry about the code this
particular code segment will be
available in our description box below
and you can always have access to it and
try to edit and run this code on your
own local system to have a better
learning experience now without further
Ado let's try to run this program
quickly and see the output
foreign
so there you go the code got
successfully executed and here you can
see the output of this particular binary
tree now let's get back to the theory
part so as discussed before followed by
the implementation part we will learn
about the properties of a binary tree
now let's discuss the properties of the
binary trees first up maximum number of
nodes at a level L is 2 to the power l
next up maximum number of nodes in a
binary tree of height H is equals to 2
to the power of H minus 1. next up
minimum possible height in a binary tree
with two nodes is equals to log of L
plus 1 base 2.
next up the minimum possible level in a
binary tree with n nodes is equals to
log of L plus 1 base 2. finally a binary
tree with L lease has at least log l
base 2 plus 1 levels
now let's discuss about the different
types of binary trees
first up we have the full binary tree
followed by that we have the complete
binary tree then we have the perfect
binary tree followed by that we have the
balanced binary tree and lastly the
degenerate binary tree let's discuss
about these in detail first Up full
binary tree a full binary tree is a
unique tree data structure in which a
node can have either two children or no
child next a complete binary tree
so a complete binary tree is another
specific binary tree where each node on
all levels except the last level must
have two children and at the lowest
level all leaves should reside possibly
on the left side
the next one is the perfect binary tree
a binary tree is perfect if every node
must have two children and every leaf is
on the same level
the next one is called as the balanced
binary tree a binary tree is balanced if
for each node the height of the left
subtree and the height of the right
subtree varies at most by just one
at last we have the degenerate binary
tree
a binary tree is said to be degenerate
if every internal node has only one
child
we have now discussed the binary tree
some terms and properties related to
Binary trees and types of boundary trees
now we will look into the operations
that needs to be performed on the binary
tree so there are basically three types
of operations that can be performed on
binary tree which are traversal
insertion and deletion
so first we'll look into the traversal
operations
there are three different types of
traversal operations possible on binary
tree which are pre-order traversal in
order traversal and finally the post
order traversal now let's get back into
the text editor mode and try to execute
our example
foreign
so right now we are on the text editor
and this particular code is for the
traversal operations on our binary tree
and here you can see we have the
structure for node and we have also the
in order function pre-order function and
post order function and don't worry
about the code this particular code will
be available in the description box
below and after you have written the
code we have some standard input over
here you can see that we are giving the
number of edges as 4 and the left
subtree elements are 2 and 1 and the
right sub three elements are 2 and 3 and
another left subtree elements are
3 and 5 and lastly we have 5 and 6 for
another left subtree now let's try to
execute this code
now we have already executed the code
and we also have the output over here
and here you can see we have entered the
number of edges as 4 and the traversal
is in order traversal which is one two
six five and three and the pre-order
traversal output is 2 1 3 5 6 and the
post order traversal is one six five
three and two now let's get back to the
PPT now we have the insertion operation
foreign
and now let's get back to our text
editor and try to see an example for
insertion operation as well
so on my screen you can see an example
for insertion operation
so here we have the insert function as I
said this particular code will be
available in the description box below
now let's provide the standard input
so the standard input will be four edges
and we have two and one as the left
subtree and two and three as right
subtree three and five as left subtree
again and 5 and 6 as the left subtree
now let's quickly run this code
and there you go the program got
successfully executed and here we have
the
output
the nodes got inserted and it has
provided an in order traversal that is
one two six five and three
now let's get back to the presentation
and the last type of operation is the
deletion operation let's quickly execute
an example based on deletion operation
as well
now as you can see we are on the text
editor again now here the example is for
deletion operation we have the delete
function over here
now for this particular program we don't
need any standard inputs so just let's
run the program
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
output over here and in order traversal
before deletion and in order traversal
after the deletion of an element
so the deleted element is element 11.
now with that let's get back to the
presentation mode again so that's how
the element got deleted now we have
reached to the last part of this session
that happens to be the final key
takeaways so what are the final
takeaways so binary tree is faster at
search operations than other type of
tree and it is easier to find maximum
and minimum elements in the binary tree
binary tree does not allow duplicate
values and draft reversal is done using
binary tree it is used to convert the
post fixed Expressions into the prefix
Expressions let's get started with
introduction to binary search tree
finance history is a set of nodes
organized in such a manner that they all
have the same binary search tree
characteristics
a key and a value is assigned to each
node
the requested key is compared to the
Keys in binary search tree
so during search if the key is found
then the corresponding value will be
retrieved
next up
properties of binary search tree
first up the left subtree of a node
contains only nodes with keys lesser
than the parent node
next up the right subtree of a node
contains only nodes that are greater
than the parent node
the left and the right subtree each must
also be a binary search tree
next let's discuss what are the
operations we can perform on a binary
search tree
First Step insertion
last deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we can insert a node in a such a way so
that we obey binary search tree rules
that is the new node should be either
less than the parent node if it's a it's
on the left subtree or if it's on the
right subtree it should be greater than
the parent node let's execute this in
the code editor
foreign
for the binary search tree so class
PST
data
and BST pointers
left
comma
right
next we will Define some functions
publicly
public
first default Constructor
and a parameterized Constructor
a function to insert the value
and a function to Traverse the node
now let's write default Constructors
definition
so BST
now let's write the parameterized
constructor's definition
BST
and
value
data
is equals to value
and left is equals to null
and
write
equals to null
now let's write the definition for the
insert function
so BST
start PST
star
root
comma
and value
now we will check if the tree is empty
or not so if
root
then we will insert the first node
we will return
you
EST
value
otherwise we will insert the data so if
the value
is greater than
root data
and
then we have to insert it
in the right subtree
so root
right
is equals to
insert
root
right
comma value
else
as the value should be inserted in the
left
side
so root
left
is equals to
insert
root
left
comma value
and then we will return
root
now let's write the Traverse function
avoid
PST
drivers
EST
AR root
if
root
then we will return
otherwise we will First Traverse
left side
then we will print the root data
and then we will Traverse
the right side
Ruth
right
now let's write the main block
so we will start with an empty tree so
BST
B
comma
star root
is equals to null
root
is equals to
B dot insert
root comma
50.
e dot insert
equals to
root comma 10.
B dot insert
gonna be root comma
e dot insert
gonna be fruit
comma 50.
sorry we already use 50 so we will use
a DOT insert
root
comma let's use 20.
let's try to Traverse this
so B Dot
Traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created and traversed our first binary
search tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following the
binary search tree rules that is the
value of the left subtree should be less
than the parent node and the value of
the right subtree should be greater than
the parent node
let's try this in a coordinator
let's start by creating a node
this time we will use structure so
struct
Ure
hint
key
product
node
start left
comma
are right
now we would create a utility function
to create a new binary search tree node
substruct
node
star
new node
and
item
.org
star
and
equals to
accept
so
star
malloc
size of
product
node
next
it'll be a sign the key is equals to
item
left
equals to null
and
damn
right
is equals to
not
now let's write a function to Traverse
the tree
Traverse
node
star
root
so if
is equals to null
Traverse
root left
Co
root
e
covers
root
right
now let's write a utility function to
insert the new node with the given key
in the binary search tree
substruct
code
insert
node
star
comma
and key
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
otherwise
we will recover down the tree so if
he
is less than
a load key
then we will insert in the left subtree
so node
left
is equals to insert
code
left
comma
key
else
node right
could be inserting
e
now let's return the node
foreign
Ty binary surgery
so we have to return the node with the
minimum key value found in that tree
so we will start
men
value node
star mode
start
current
is equals to node
so we will look down to find the left
most leaves
so
while
current
and
parents left
is not equals to null
so current
should be equals to
current
return
node star
delete
node
product
note star
root comma and key
f
root
equals to null
return
root
now if the key to be deleted is smaller
than the roots key then it lies in the
left subtree so we will check if
e
less than
root key
then root
left
it will be equals to
delete node
root left key
comma key
now if the key is deleted
is greater than the roots key then it
lies in the right sub trees so else
he is greater than root
root
right
is equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma key
else
if
Roots dot left
equals to null
and
root
dot right
is equals to null
then return
else
if
root
that
equals to null
then struct
node
star
is equals to
root
right
and free
root
return
temp
late
roots
right
is equals to null
then strapped
out star
jump
is equals to root
root
return
temp
now node with the two children get the
in order successor smallest in the right
subtree
so struct
note star
temp
is equals to
Min value
node
root
right
right now we will copy the inorder
successors content to this node so root
is equals to temp
now we will delete the in order
successor so root
right
equals to
delete
code
right
comma temp
orary
now we will return root
now let's write the main block
we will start with an empty tree
product
node star
root
is equals to
null
now root is equals to
insert
root comma
2.
root
is equals to insert
comma 5.
root is equals to insert
oh
comma
three
root is equals to insert
root
comma 4
is equals to
insert
root comma
seven
and root
equals to insert
root comma
six
let's try to Traverse this so C out
traversal
of the given
me
hours
root
now first we will delete a value to see
out
delete
two
a root is equals to delete
node
root comma
to
RC out
traversal
after
deleting
Traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
deleted two and Traverse the tree again
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up left side notes are always
lesser than the parents know and the
right side note are always more than the
parent node
next it is easier to search and sort
elements in a binary search tree
finally a binary search tree offers
faster insertion and deletion operations
what is recursion
well recursion is a process in which a
function repeatedly calls itself either
directly or indirectly those calls are
majorly done by explicitly calling
function by its name however it can also
be accomplished by implicit calling as
well the fundamental idea behind calling
the function over and over again is to
break a larger problem into smaller sub
problems we do this for reducing the
computational complexity of a larger
Problem by breaking it into several
pieces this tactic is also called as
divide and conquer approach in
programming so now you must be thinking
about how we can break the larger
problem into smaller sub problems well
to do that we break the given problem
statement into two parts the first one
is base case and the second one is
recursive step
the base case is nothing but the
simplest instance of a problem that
consists of condition which holds the
recursive function given the function
calls argument this base case computes
the output of our program right away
whereas in the recursive step we compute
the result using one or more recursive
calls to the same function but with the
inputs decrease in size or complexity to
understand this breakdown let's have a
look at mathematical aspect of recursion
suppose you have to formulate a
mathematical function for computing the
sum of N natural numbers that means the
function that you are going to create
must calculate the summation of all
natural numbers in the range 0 to n
mathematically it can be represented as
summation of all numbers from K is equal
to 0 to K is equal to n now the critical
question here is how can we actually
represent this in form of recursive
function the answer is quite simple all
we need to do is break this larger
problem into small fragments we can
represent this problem as n plus sum of
all natural numbers till n minus 1. this
process of traversing in function f n
minus 1 times is called the recursive
step of our problem statement whereas
the base case is a condition which is
stopping the recursion when K is
reaching value 0. in terms of
programming it can be represented using
a vlog now I hope you guys have
understood how we can break a larger
problem into smaller sub problems moving
further we are going to understand how
recursion gets executed in memory area
in order to do that we'll take this C
program as an example in this program we
have two methods the main method
contains one variable and the statement
that invokes a function name fun
this function fun is making a recursive
call in its function body we have both
base case and recursive step inside this
function's body now whenever a function
is called its activation record will be
maintained inside the stack
so for this program we are going to look
into its control flow as we know the
main function gets invoked primarily by
an operating system thus will include
the main function at first in our memory
stack this activation record will
consist of local variables of function
parameters and the record of return
address to the caller but here for the
sake of Simplicity we are just
maintaining the local variables inside
the activation record after this step as
you can see the main function is
activating method fun with argument 3.
once activated it will prompt 3 on
screen and will invoke one three minus 1
that is fund 2. now again as 2 is
greater than 0 the control will invoke
fund 2 minus 1 that is fun one after
this the control will activate fund 0.
this time once the control enters an if
block it will execute a return statement
and activation record 0 will get popped
out of the memory stack further every
function inside the memory stack will
get popped out from it which will result
in generation of output the output that
will get printed on the console for this
particular program is three two one
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer based on
the properties of recursion that we have
discussed till now which of the
following statement seems right to you
the options that we have are recursion
is always better than iteration option b
recursion uses more memory compared to
the iteration option C recursion uses
less memory compared to the iteration
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right so guys
do leave your answers to this question
in comment section Below in a week's
time we'll be announcing the right
answer and you all can check it out now
moving ahead we'll discuss different
types of recursion in programming
there are basically four types of
recursion the first one is direct
recursion the second one is indirect
recursion the third one is tail
recursion and the fourth one is non-till
recursion so let's discuss direct
recursion
a function is called direct recursive if
it calls itself in its function body
over and over again to better understand
this definition let's look at the
structure of a program that is direct
recursive in nature in this program we
have a method name fun which is calling
itself again and again in its function
body thus we can say that it is direct
recursive in nature
next up is indirect recursion
the recursion in which the function
calls itself via another function is
called as indirect recursion
for example in this program you can
clearly see that the function fun one is
explicitly calling fund 2 which is
invoking fun one again explicitly hence
we can say that this is an example of
indirect recursion further we have tail
recursion a recursive function is said
to be tail recursive if the recursive
call is the last execution done by the
function let's try to understand this
definition with the help of an example
If You observe this program you can see
that the last line ADI will execute for
method fun is recursive call and because
of that there is no need to remember any
previous state of our program
finally we have a non-tailed recursive
function on our list
a recursive function is said to be
non-tail recursive if the recursion call
is not the last thing done by the
function after returning back there is
something left to evaluate let's
consider one example in this function
you can clearly observe that there is
another operation after the recursive
call hence our ADI will have to memorize
the previous state and set this memory
block that is why this program can be
considered as non-tailed recursive now
finally let's Implement a program to
demonstrate the recursion
the program that we are going to
implement is solution to the problem
statement that we discussed earlier
according to that problem statement we
have to calculate the sum up and natural
numbers given the number n now in order
to address this problem we are going to
use C programming language so without
any further Ado let's head over to the
code editor
now in order to get started with coding
implementation first we'll create an
utility function to calculate sum of N
natural numbers so let's do that
and will pass an argument and and
now we have arrived inside the body of
function sum what we'll first do is
we'll calculate sum of N minus 1 natural
numbers by making an recursive call to
function sum so let's do that
sum n minus 1
and we'll store this value inside a
temporary variable
now we'll add this temporary variables
value to n in order to return it as a
result
foreign
statements that we just wrote are called
as recursive steps But If You observe
this statement we are not putting any
limitation to our recursive call so that
is why I will have to add base case to
our function so let's do that
if
n equal to equal to 0
then
return
0.
with this we have successfully
implemented a sum function
so let's work on our driver method to
generate the result
and this driver method
first will create an variable n
and after that we'll write a printf
statement
enter
the natural
number
n
to calculate
the sum of
n numbers
semicolon and in next line we'll write
scan app statement in order to take
input from our user so
inside this we'll write modulus d
comma ambrosion n
and semicolon
and in next statement we'll make a call
to us some function in order to
calculate sum of N natural numbers so
how we can do that well we can add
modulus D here
comma
sum
and
semicolon
and I hope a code works fine now so
let's check it by compiling
here the console is asking us to provide
with value of variable n and I am going
to provide value 5 here so let's provide
value 5
and enter so the output that we are
getting is 15 here that means a code
works fine recursion it is one of those
topics which tends to blend with almost
every other category in the programming
world
interviewers always ask questions based
on recursion to gauge candidates problem
solving abilities because this topic
pushes the candidates limit and
differentiate them between good and
exceptional in this session we will
discuss some of the commonly used
recursion problems asked in the
interviews
we will calculate the sum of numbers
from 0 to a given number
we will start with creating a function
sum in function definition we will first
check if the given number is 0 or 1.
then we will return the number else we
will return addition of that number with
the recursive sum function with n minus
1 as an argument
now let's try it in the code editor
we will write a function and
sum
argument and num
we will check
if
num is equals to 0
or
num is equals to 1.
if yes then we will return
num
else
it will return
num
Plus
sum
of
n minus 1.
now we will write the code for the main
block
we will declare end n comma press
we will call CN
to take the input data
then we will equal rest equals to
sum
at n
then we will print this sum
son
yes
now let's try and execute this program
we will give argument as 5.
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly let's get back to our slides
now let's move on to our next question
we will discuss a recursive function to
find the factorial of given number
we will start with creating a function
fact in function definition we will
first check if the given number is less
than or equal to
1 then we will return 1 else we will
return multiplication of that number
with a recursive fact function called
with n minus 1 as an argument
now let's try that in a coordinator we
will start with function and fact
argument and
and
if
n is less than equals to 1
then we will return
1.
else
we will return
and multiplied by recursive function
at
with n minus 1 as argument
now let's write the code for the main
block
so we will declare variables end and
comma rest
we'll take input from the user
now rest is equals to fact
n
now we will try to print the value of
rice
so
factorial
Plus
let's try and execute this
we will find the factorial of 5 which is
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly it is getting us the value of
factorial 5 which is 120. let's get back
to our slides if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then we will
do our next question
we will discuss a recursive function to
find the nth Fibonacci number
we will start with creating a function
Fibonacci in this function's definition
we will first check if the given number
is less than or equal to 1. then we will
return that number as we will return the
sum of recursive function Fibonacci with
n minus 1 as an argument and recursive
function Fibonacci with n minus 2 as an
argument
now let's try to do that in the codator
let's start by creating a function and
we both
with argument as int and
we will first check if n is less than
equals to 1.
if yes then we will return
and
otherwise we will return
sum of
recursive function favor
at n minus 1.
and the Fibonacci function
n minus 2.
let's write code for the mean block
we'll start with variable and
comma rest
we will call CN function to get user
value for n
then we will store the value of
Fibonacci function in dress
now we will call Print function say out
to print the value of rest
so Annette Fibonacci
number
is equals to rest
return
zero
let's try and execute this
we will check the Fibonacci number at
Ninth position which is 34.
as you can see we are getting the value
as 34 that is our function is working
flawlessly let's get back to our slides
now we will move forward with the next
question
we will be discussing a recursive
function that can check if a string is
spelling wrong or not
we will start with creating a Boolean
function in is parallel
with an argument as string Str integer
low
and integer High
first we will check if the string has at
least one character or not
then we will compare the first character
and the last character if a mismatch
happened then we will return false
otherwise we will move to our next pair
by recalling the recursive function with
incrementing low and decrementing high
by 1.
now let's try this in the code editor we
will start by creating a recursive
function to check if Str from low to
high is a palindrome or not here the low
defines the first index and high Define
the last index
so we will write a Boolean function
is violin
with argument as string
Str
Oma
end
row comma and I
will check for Star base case
so if
low is greater than equals to high
then we will return
group
now we will check if
the first character
is
equal to the last character
return false
now we will move to the next pair so
return
is
balance
with argument as Str comma
low plus 1
comma hi
minus 1.
now let's write the code for the main
block
so
we will take string
here
is equals to
Malayalam
now we will check if
alien
it
now we will find the length of this
string so end
alien
is equals to
Str
dot length
now we will check
yes
is spelling
from Str comma 0
to comma
l a n
minus one
it is true then it will give C out
we will print palindra
and ROM
else
they will print
not
a palindrome
let's try and execute this in the code
editor
as you can see it is saying that it is a
palindrome which is correct so a
function is working flawlessly let's get
back to our slides
finally we will discuss a recursive
function that can reverse a given string
we will start but with creating a
function reverse
with an argument a string Str integer
low and integer High
first we will check if the string is
greater than one character or not if yes
then we will swap them
then we will move to our next pair by
calling the recursive function reverse
with incrementing low and decrementing
high by 1.
now let's try this code in the code
editor
we will start with creating a recursive
function but before that we will include
a special Library
include
algorithm
now
boiled
reverse
ring
and person Str
note that we have passed the string as a
reference parameter
so
end hi
now we will check if
low
is less than
High
if yes then we will swap
Str
at low
comma
Str
at High
then we will call the recursive function
reverse
to move to a next pair
Str
Oma low plus 1
comma hi
minus one
let's write code for the main block
we will write string
ER
which is equals to
simply learn
now we will reverse
yeah comma 0
comma
here dot length
minus one
now C out
reverse
of the string
here
equals to
CR
op let's try and execute this
as you can see this version is working
flawlessly as it has reversed the word
simply enough
an able tree is a height balanced binary
search tree for each node we have to
make sure that the height of the left
subtree and the right substrate can
differ by at most one we can calculate
this balance Factor by subtracting the
height of the left subtree from the
height of the right sub tree now let's
discuss various rotations we can perform
on avial trees first up LL rotation next
are our rotations next LR rotation at
last RL rotation let's discuss them in
detail first up LL rotation it is a
clockwise rotation when a node is
inserted on the left subtree of the left
subtree of a node then we apply this
rotation to balance the tree it is
applied on the Node below the balance
Factor 2 node that is we will apply
right rotation on the green node next
are our rotation when a node is inserted
into a right subtree of the right
subtree of a node then we perform RR
rotation it is an anti-clockwise
rotation which is applied on the Node
below a node having balance Vector minus
2 that is we will apply it on the green
node
next up LR rotation
when a node is inserted into right
subtree of the left subtree of a node
then we perform alerts rotation
it is a combination of RR and LL
rotation
first we will apply error rotation on
green and yellow node
after this red node is still unbalanced
so we will perform LL rotation on the
yellow node
finally
RL rotation
when a node is inserted into the left
subtree of right subtree of a node then
we perform RL rotation
it is a combination of LL and RR
rotation
first we will apply LL rotation on green
and yellow nodes
with this the red node is still
unbalanced so we will perform error
rotation on the yellow node now let's
discuss complexity of AVL trees
first up space complexity is a bigger of
n
next up AVL tree offers a complexity of
bigger of log n for searching
next up
AV trees offer a complexity of bigger of
log n for insertion
finally AVL tree offers a complexity of
bigger of log n of for deletion
we have now introduced an avial tree and
rotations on it now let's discuss some
of the operations we can perform on
avial trees
first up insertion
and deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we will insert a node following binary
search tree rules then we will check if
the nodes are balanced or not if they
are not then we will balance it by using
suitable rotations now let's try these
operations in a code editor let's start
by creating a node to create a node we
need a class node
we will create its member as public
and key
dot star left
dot Star right
now let's write a function to get
maximum of two integers
so and Max
a
comma and B
now let's declare a utility function to
get maximum of two integers
so end Max
a comma and V
now let's write a function to get the
height of the tree
and
height
node
star
and
now if n is null
then we will return 0.
else we will return
and calls
height
now let's write that function to get
maximum of two integers hint Max
int a
comma
ENT B
we will return
if
a is greater than b
then we will return a else we will
return B
now let's write a helper function that
allocates a new node with a given key
and null left and right pointers
thank you so note
star
new node
End Key
code
star
node
equals to new
so node
key
will be equals to key
node
left
will be equals to
the left
node left
will be equals to null
and node
right
will be equals to null
and node
yeah
right
will be equals to 1.
and return
node
here we have kept height as 1 because at
the new node is initially added at Leaf
so by default it will always be at 1.
now let's write a utility function to
write rotate sub tree rooted with y
node
star
right
about star y
foreign
is equals to Y is left
and
node
star
E2 is equals to
X
right
now we will perform rotation so X right
will become y
and Y is left
will become T2
now we will update the heights so why
height
is equals to Max
of
height
of Y left
comma
hi
of
pi
site
plus one
now
X
height
equals to
maximum of
height
X
left
comma
height
of
X
right
plus one
now return
X
now let's write a utility function to
left rotate sub tree rooted with x
so node
on left rotate
about star X
node star y
will be equals to access right
and node
star T2 will be equals to excess
sorry
twice as
now we will perform rotation so why
left
will be equals to X
and
X
right
will be equals to T2
now let's update Heights so X
height
is equals to
maximum of
height
of X is left
comma height
of
X is right
and
Wise height
equals to maximum of
height
of
Y is left
comma
height
of
wise right
return
by
now let's write a function to get
balanced Vector of node n
so end
that
balance
argument as node pointer and
if
n is not n is equals to null
then we will return
0.
otherwise
we will return
height
of
ends
left
minus
height of
hence right
now let's write a recursive function to
insert a key in the sub tree rooted with
node and Returns the new root of the
subtree
so
node
star
insert
notes
star
node
comma hint key
now we'll perform the normal BST
insertion so if
node is equals to null
then we will return
new
node
key
now if
this key
is less than
nodes key
then
load
left
will equals to
insert
node
left
comma key
or else
we will insert that in the right node
right
is equals to insert
node
right
comma t
now we will return node
this if else will make sure that we will
reach to the leaf node and then we will
insert the key
now we will update the height of the
sensor node
so node
height
is equals to 1 plus
Max
height
of
code
left
comma
height
of node
right
now we will get the balance factor for
this ancestor now to check whether this
node became unbalanced so int balance
is equals to get
balance
now if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases
so if
balance
is greater than 1.
and E
is less than
about
left
key
then we will return
right
rotate
note
this if statement for the left left case
so or allele case
now let's write it for the right IDs or
RR case so if
balance
is less than -1
okay
and
e
is greater than
node
right
key
yeah
then
we will return
left
rotate
node
now write for the left right case or LR
case so if
balance
is greater than 1.
and
key
is greater than node
left
key
the node
left
is equals to
left rotate
node
foreign
left
out return
right
rotate
now let's write the right left case or
RL case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
key is less than node
to the right
key
and node
right
will be equals to
write
rotate
node
to the right
and we will return
left
totally
now we will return this node
now let's write a function to print
pre-order traversal of this tree
so avoid
pre-order
code
star root
so now if
root is not null
then
C out
root
key
and now three
order
root
and pre-order
now let's write the code for the mean
block
we will start with an empty tree a node
star root is equals to null
now we will try to construct tree
yeah root
is equals to
insert
root comma 10
root
is equals to insert
root comma 5.
root
is equals to insert
comma
root is equals to insert
root
comma 3
is equals to insert
root comma seven
and root is equals to insert
um
comma
9.
now let's try to print this tree
so C out
Avia
tree
is equals to
three
and
three order
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first Avia tree let's get
back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following a binary
search tree rules then we will check if
all the nodes are balanced or not if
they are not then we will balance it by
using suitable rotations
now let's try these operations in a
coordinator
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class
node
we will Define its members as public
and key
node star left
node Star right
and height
now
let's write a utility function to get
height of the tree so end
height
node
star m
f
n is equals to null
then in that case we will return 0
otherwise we will return
hence height
now let's write a utility function to
get maximum of two integer
and
Max
and a comma int B
so we will return
if a is greater than b
then a
else
B
now let's write a helper function that
allocates a new node with a given key
and null left and right pointers
so node
star
new node
int
key
so node
star
new node
is equals to new
node parenthesis
Now new node
will get key
as
key
new node
left
is equals to null
and new node
right
is equals to null
and new nodes height
is equals to 1. because new node is
initially added as leaf that's why it is
always be given as one
now we will return this node return
node
now let's write a utility function to
right rotate a sub tray rooted with y
so node
are
right rotate
mode
star y
OT star X
is equals to
y left
node
dot D2
is equals to
X
right
now we will perform rotation so X
is equals to y
by
left
is equals to T2
now we will update Heights
so why
equals to maximum of
height
of
Y is left
comma
height
of
wise
right
plus one
and
x height
is equals to
maximum of
height
of
axis left
foreign
access right
plus one
now we will return this new root so
return
X
now we will write
node
star left rotate
node star
X
4 star y
will be equals to X is right
and
or Star T2
will be equals to Y is left
now we'll perform rotation so why
left
equals to X
and X
right
is equals to T2
now we will update these Heights so X
height
is equals to maximum of
of X that
comma height
of
X right
plus one
and
Wise height
is equals to Max of height
of
twice left
comma height
of
wise right
plus one
now we will return this y
now we will write a function to get
balance factor of node n so int
capital
get balance
node star n
so if
n is equals to null
all right then we will return
0.
otherwise we will return
height
of
ends left
minus
height
of
ends like
now let's write a function to insert a
node
so node
start insert
it's a node
star
node
comma
int
key
now we will perform normal BST rotation
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
so now if
is less than node key
then
node
left
will be equals to insert
node
left
comma key
of f
e
is greater than node key
then node
right
is equals to
insert
node
right
comma key
else
we will return
node because like equal keys are not
allowed
now we will update the height of the
ancestral node so node
height
plus 2
1 plus
X
height
of node
left
comma height
of node
right
now we will get the balance factor of
this ancestral node to check whether
this node becomes unbalanced
so if
end
balance
equals to
get
balance
of this node
now if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases that could be
possible
so if
balance
is greater than
one
and
key
is less than node
left
e
return
right
rotate
code
now let's write write that case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
key is
greater than node
right
key
then we will return
left
rotate
node
now let's write left right case
so if
balance
is greater than 1.
and
e
is greater than node
left
key
and
node
left
will be equals to
the left rotate
node
and we will return
right
rotate
now let's write the case for right left
case
if
balance
is less than minus one
and
e
is less than
node
right
so node
is equals to
write rotate
node
right
now we will return
left rotate
note
now let's return the unchanged node
pointer
on return
node
now let's write a function to find
minimum value node
so node star
men
value
dot star node
so node
star
and
equals to node
so while
current
left
is not equals to null
current
is equals to current
at left
now we will return current
now we will write a recursive function
to delete a node with the given key from
subtree with the given root
so node
star
delete node
its arguments are not pointer root
comma ENT key
for starters we will perform standard
BST delete so if
root is equals to null
then we will return
root
now if the key to be deleted is smaller
than the root key then it lies in the
left subtree so
if
e is less than root
e
then root
left
will be equals to
delete
node
root to the left
comma key
now if key to deleted is greater than
the root key then it lies in the right
subtree so else
if
e is greater than root
e
then
root right
equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma key
now if the key is same as the root key
then this is the node to be deleted so
else
if
root
left
equals to l
uh
root
to the right
is equals to null
then node
star
temp
is equals to root
left
now if
temp
is equals total
the temp
will be equals to root
and root
l equals to null
else
root
will be equals to start temp
and three
temp
let's
node
start time
is equals to
main value node
root
right
now we will copy the in order successors
data to this node
so root
e
is equals to temp
key
now we will delete this in order
successor so root
right
is equals to
delete
code
comma
10th
key
if
root
is equals to null
then we will return
root
now we will update the height of the
current node
so root
right
is equals to 1 plus
Max
of height
of roots
left
comma
height
of
foreign height
of root
height
now we will get the balance factor of
this node
so
and
balance
is equals to
get
balance
root
if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases
first up LL case
so if
balance
is greater than one
and
that balance
of
roots
left
is greater than equals to zero
then we will return
right rotate
now if
balance
is greater than 1.
and
get balance
of root
left
Less Than Zero
then
root
left
will equals to left rotate
root
that
now we will return
right
rotate
put
now let's write write that case so if
balance
less than minus 1.
and
get balance
is less than equals to zero
then we will return
left rotate
now we will write right left case so if
balance
is less than -1
and
get balance
of root
right
is greater than zero
then
root
right
is equals to
write rotate
root
right
now we will return
left rotate
and we will return this route
now let's write a function to print
pre-order traversal of this tree
so void
free order
code
star root
so if
root
not equals to null
and C out
root
a
pre-order
root
left
and pre-order
root
right
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with an empty tree so node
root
is equals to
null
now root
is equals to insert
2 comma
two
root is equals to insert
yeah
root comma
10.
root is equals to insert
root
comma 9
is equals to insert
root comma seven
root is equals to insert
root comma 5.
is equals to insert
root comma 3.
now let's try and print this of evil
tree
so C out
created
AVL
P order
two three are the
now we will delete a node so root
is equals to
delete
node
fruit comma
now let's again try and print this
so C out
dated
three
three order
after
deletion
of 10
layout
handle
pray order
root
it
now let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly now let's get back to
our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up avial trees is a self-balancing
binary search tree next every node must
have a balance factor of either minus 1
0 or 1. next after every rotation we
must verify if each node is balanced or
not
finally AVL trees offers fast insertion
and deletion operations
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
let's get started with what is battery
a b tree is a special ambulatory data
structure
a b tree of order M can have at most M
minus 1 keys and M children
now let's discuss some properties of B
trees
first up every node in a b tree can have
at most M elements
next every node except the root and the
leaf node must have M by two children
next a root node must have at least two
nodes
at last a leaf node must be at the same
level
now let's discuss what are the various
operations we can perform on a battery
we can perform three operations on a b
tree that is searching insertion and
deletion
let's discuss these in detail
first up searching in this we will
Traverse the complete battery until we
have found a key we will start from the
left side to go all the way up to the
right side
now let's try this in a code editor we
will first start by creating a b tree
node to do that we will use class
betray node
and
case
it is an array of keys
then int
t
this will Define the range of the number
of keys
then we will create a child pointer
eat Shri
note
see
it is an array of child pointer
then
then a variable uh to check the current
number of keys
and a Boolean variable
which will be true when the node is leaf
now Define some functions in public
first Constructor
then a function to insert a new key in a
sub tree
void
insert
non-full
argument as print k
foreign
utility function to split the child y of
the node
argument as int I
comma
a b tray node pointer
by
a function to Traverse the battery
and a function to search a key in the
subtree
it will return null if K is not present
foreign
and make it a friend of this so that we
can access private members of this
battery of this class in B tree function
now we will create a pointer root
minimum degree
then public
foreign
and T is equals to
this code t
now we will write a function to Traverse
this tree
call it Traverse
if
foreign
now we will write a function to search a
key in this tree
return
if root is equals to null
and null
else
root
urge
now the main function that inserts the
new key in this B tree
word
insert
and okay
now we will write the Constructor for B3
node class
now we will copy the given minimum
degree and leave property
now we will allocate the memory of the
maximum number of possible keys and the
child pointer
foreign
now we will initialize the number of
keys at zero
now let's write the function to Traverse
all node in the sub tree rooted with
this node
there are n keys and N plus 1 children
to Traverse through n keys and first and
children's we need to do int eyes
equals to zero
I less than none
I plus plus
if this is not Leaf node then before
printing key
Traverse the subtree rooted with child
CEI
so if
is equals to false
done
C bracket I
l equals to
Traverse
else C out
case
now we will print the subtree rooted
with the last node
so if
leave
is equals to false
and C
I
was
now we'll write the function to search
key K in sub tray rooted with this node
so
B tree node
are
a tree or
search
and K
we will first find the first key greater
than or equal to K
so
while
and I
is less than n
and
K is greater than
is
bracket I
then I plus plus
now if we found the key is equals to k
then we will return this node
if
bracket I
is equals to K
then we will
return
if key is not found here and this is the
leaf node then
if
Leaf is equals to
true
then we will return
now we will try to go to the appropriate
child
so we will use return
C bracket I
Arrow search
now we will write the main function that
inserts a new key in this victory
so void
B tree
insert
and K
so if
root
is equals to
null
then we will allocate the memory of 4
root
foreign
keys
record zero
is equals to K
now we will change root
here we are updating the number of keys
in this root
you know
if else
as if tree is not empty
then
if root is full then tree grows in
height so if
root Arrow n
is equals to
to start t
minus 1
.
then we will allocate the memory for the
new root
B tree
or
star s
equals to new
tree
node
T comma false
yeah
now we'll make the old root a child of
the new root
so s Arrow
C bracket zero
is equals to
root
now we will split the old Route and move
one key to the new root
so
s
ick child
0 comma root
thank you
Now new root has two childrens
we have to decide which of the two
children is going to have an EQ new key
so int I is equals to zero
f
foreign
then I plus plus
and as Arrow C bracket I
Arrow foreign
now we will change the root
equals to s
if root is not full we are called the
insert non-full
now we will write a function insert for
non full
foreign
is equals to
n minus 1
f
if
equals to
true
then while
I is greater than equals to zero
and
if
is greater than k
then case
I plus 1
will be equals to key is I
and I minus minus
now we will insert the new key at the
found location
foreign
I is greater than equals to zero
is
I is greater than
k
then I minus minus
now we will see if the found child is
full
if
C
like a i plus 1
and
and equals to
2 Star t
minus 1
.
done
we will use split child
I plus 1
comma
C
I plus 1
.
now if
keys
bracket 5 plus 1
Which is less than k
then I plus plus
foreign
okay
now we will write the function split
child
okay
foreign
equals to
D minus one
now four dope
and
J is equals to zero
J less than T minus one
J plus plus
Z equals to
okay
equals to y
now we will copy the last two children's
of Phi to Z
if
why leaf
is equals to false
then four
enter J
is equal to zero
J less than t
and J plus plus
now we will reduce repeat now we will
reduce the number of keys in y
foreign
this node is going to have a new child
we will create a space for the new child
so for Loop
and J is equals to 9 J is equals to n
J greater than equals to
I plus 1
J minus minus
C bracket
J plus 1
equals to C bracket J
now we will link the new child to this
node
now a key of Y will move to this node
and find the location of new key and
move all greater Keys one space ahead
now we will increment the count of keys
in this node
now let's write the main block
we will Define a b tree with minimum
degree 3.
now T dot insert
.
T dot insert
dot insert
five
two dot insert
six
D dot insert
a DOT insert
.
D dot insert
seven
and D dot insert
foreign
Ty
now let's try to Traverse this
say out
traversal
of
P3
and T Dot
also
now let's search some keys so let's take
end
K is equals to 6
so if
D dot search
k
is not
null
done C out
else
see out
not present
let's try this function one more time
with K is equals to
15.
let's execute this
foreign
traversed this B tree and we have
checked two keys if they are present or
not the K is equals to 15 was not
present and K is equal to 6 was present
let's get back to our slides
next up insertion
we have to insert an element in such a
way so that we won't disobey any
properties of B trees
now let's try this operation in a code
editor
we will start by creating a node to do
that we will use Class B tree node
then we will create an array of keys
minimum degree
an array of child pointers
current number of keys
and a Boolean variable leaf
this variable will tell if the node is
leaf or not
then we will Define some public
functions
we will start with Constructor
now we will create a function to insert
a new key into the non-fold node
a utility function to split the child
foreign
class big tree
now we will create this class B tree
foreign
a pointer to root node
minimum degree
then we will create some public
functions
first Constructor
root equals to
null
and T equals to
underscore t
now
void
Traverse
now if
root is not equational
then root
Arrow
Traverse
now we will Define a main function that
inserts a new key in this battery
now we will write the Constructor for
the B tree dot class
and T1
comma Boolean
Leaf one
now we will copy the given minimum
degree and leave property
now we will allocate memory of maximum
number of possible keys and child
pointers
now we will initialize the number of
keys as 0
.
now let's write a function to Traverse
all node in the sub tree
now there are n keys and N plus one
children so we will Traverse through n
keys and first and Central
so end
I
follow
I is equal to 0
foreign
now suppose if this is not leaf then
before printing key we will Traverse the
sub tree rooted with this child
so
if
is equals to false
length C
I
Arrow
Traverse
now we will print these keys
now we will print the sub tree rooted
with the last child
so if
leave
is equals to
false
then
see I
Arrow
Traverse
now we will write the main function that
inserts a new key in this B tree
void
B tree
and K
now if tree is empty
then we will allocate the memory to root
so root
is equals to new
B tree node
e comma true
now we will insert the key
root
Arrow
keys
equals to K
and we will update the number of keys in
root
Arrow
and
equals to 1.
else
if tree is not empty
and if root is full then tree will grow
in height
if
root
Arrow n
is equals to
start T minus 1
now we will allocate the memory of new
root
now we will make all root as child of
new root
is equals to
root
now we will split the old Route and move
one key to the new root
so to do that we'll use split child
function
0 comma suit
Now new root has two childrens now
we have to decide which of the two
children is going to have new key
so to do that we will use end high is
equals to zero
if
s case
0 is less than k
then I plus plus
and S
Arrow C I
not full
now we will change the root
else
root
insert
non-full
k
now we will write a utility function to
insert a new kid in this node
we will assume the node must be non-full
when this function is called
so void
B tree
node
insert non-full
and K
we will initialize index as index of
rightmost element
so int I is equals to n minus 1.
now if this is a leaf node
then the following Loop does two things
a finds a location of new key to be
inserted or move all greater keys to one
place ahead
so while
I is greater than equals to 0
and
is
I
is greater than k
now
is
I plus 1
will be equals to
keys at I
and I minus minus
now we will insert the new key at the
found location
so please
at I plus 1
will be equals to K
and n equals to n Plus 1.
now else
if this node is not Leaf then we'll find
the child which is going to have the new
key so while
I is greater than equals to 0.
and
is
I
is greater than k
then
I plus I minus minus
now we will see if the farm child is
full
so if
c i plus 1
Arrow n
is equals to
star t
minus 1.
okay
now if the child is full then we will
split it
so
split
child
at I plus 1
comma
c i Plus 1.
after split the middle key of C i goes
up and c i is splitted into two now we
will see which of the following will
have the new key
if
keys
I plus 1
is
less than k
then I plus plus
C
I plus 1
insert
non full
okay
child
and I comma
a tree
node
now we will create a new node which is
going to store T minus keys of Y
so B tree
node
.z
equals to
new
E3
node
by Arrow
t
comma
y Arrow
leave
now Z Arrow n
is equals to T minus 1.
now we will copy the last T minus 1 case
of Y to Z
so for Loop
and J is equals to zero
a less than T minus 1
J plus plus
so Z
Arrow
is
J
equals to
y Arrow
is
J plus t
now we will copy the last three
children's of Y to Z
so
if
why Leaf is false
so for
and J is equals to 0
foreign
CJ
is equals to
y
C
J plus t
now we will reduce the number of keys in
y
so y
Arrow n
is equals to T minus 1.
now since the node is going to have a
new child we will create the space for
the new child
so for
integer is equals to n
and J is greater than equals to I plus 1
foreign
C
J plus 1
will be equals to
C J
now we will link the new child to this
node
so C bracket I plus 1
equals to Z
now a key of Y will move to this node
so we will find the location of new key
and move all greater case one space
ahead
so for
and
J
is equals to
n minus 1.
J greater than equals to I
J minus minus
is
a plus one
equals to
is
J
now we will copy the middle key of Y to
this node
so key is
tracker
I
is equals to
y
Arrow
keys at T minus 1
.
now we will increment the counts of key
in this node so n equals to n plus 1
now we will write a driver program to
test above functions
foreign
now we will insert keys in this tree
so e Dot
insert
10.
T dot insert
15.
T Dot insert
life
5 T dot insert
X
T dot insert
e Dot
insert
seven
now let's spread this Constructor tree
So Co
created
B tree
s
now T dot Traverse
now let's execute this
as we can see we have created a b tree
of order 3. let's get back to our slides
finally deletion
while deleting any elements from B tree
we have to be careful not to break any
properties of the battery like all the
leaves must be present at the same level
or elements must be in ascending order
now let's try this operation in a code
editor
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class
node
end
start keys
this is an array of keys
entity
a minimum degree
now we will define an array of child
pointers
so B tree node
there are number of keys and and
a Boolean variable leave to tell us if
the node is leaf or not
now we will Define some public functions
we will start with the Constructor to
this class B tree
node
and underscore t
comma Boolean
underscore leaf
and a function to Traverse the all nodes
in the sub rooted tree
so void
drivers
now a function to search a key in the
subtree
so B tree
node
star
search
and K
this one returns null if K is not
present
now we will write a function that
Returns the index of the first key that
is greater or equal to K so in
find key
and okay
foreign
now we'll write an iterative function to
insert a new key in this subtree rooted
with this node we will be assuming the
node must be non-full when this function
is called
so void
insert
non-full
as argument as k
now we will write a utility function to
split the child of Y
of this node
void
child
and
I comma
B tree node
star y
a wrapper function is to remove the keys
k in substituted with this node
so avoid
remove
entry
foreign
to remove a key present in the ith ith
position in this node which is a known
Leaf node so void
remove
from non-leaf
and
idx
now we will write a function to get the
predecessor of the key where the key is
present in the idx proportion in the
node
so end
get
red
and idx
now we will write a function to get the
successor of the key where the key is
present in the idx position in the node
so and
get successor
and idx
now we will write a function to fill up
the child node present in the idx
position
in the C array if that child has less
than T minus 1 keys
avoid
fill
and idx
now we will write another function to
borrow a key from the c i t x minus 1
node and place it and plus it in C idx
node
so void
borrow
from
it idx
a function to borrow a key from the idx
plus one node and place it at the I idx
node so void
borrow
from
next
and
idx
void
merge
RDX
now we will make B3 class as friend so
that we can access private members of
the this class in the B3 functions
so friend
class
B tree
foreign
we'll start with the pointer to the root
node
so B3
star root
and T
now we'll write some public functions
we will start with the Constructor so B
tree
and
underscore t
so root
is equals to null
and T is equals to
underscore p
foreign
function void Traverse
so we will check if
root is not null
then
root
Arrow
Traverse
now we will write a function to search a
key in this tree
so B tree
node
search
and K
we will return
if
root is equals to
null
then we will return null
else
truth
Arrow
search at Key
now we'll write the mean function that
inserts a new key in this bit rate so
avoid
insert
int k
now another main function that removes
the new key in this battery
so void
and move
and
now we will write the Constructor for
this big tray node
us
entity one comma
bull
leaf
one
so T will be equals to T1
and
leave
will be equals to leave one
now we will allocate memory for the
maximum number of possible keys and
child pointers so key is
equals to new
int
bracket to start t
minus 1.
and child C is equals to Nu
B tree node
star bracket to Star t
now we will initialize the number of
keys as zero so n is equals to zero
now we will write a utility function
that Returns the index of the first e
that is greater than or equal to K
so end
B tree
node
find
key
and J
now end
idx is equals to zero
then while
idx
is less than n
and
keys
idx
is less than k
plus plus
idx
returned
now we will write a function to remove
the key K from the sub tree rooted with
this node so void
D3
node
remove
end okay
and
idx equals to
Point Key
k
if the key to be removed is present in
this node then
idx
is less than n
and
keys
at idx
is equals to K
now if node is leaf node
then we will remove from Leaf node is
called
otherwise remove from non-leaf function
is called
so if
leave
then remove
from
leaf
idx
else
remove
from
only
idx
now else
if this node is a leaf node then the key
is not present industry so if
leave
sealed
is
is not
exist
industry
and return
the key to be removed is present in this
sub tree rooted with this node the flag
indicates whether the key is present in
this sub tree rooted with the last child
of this node
foreign
flag
is equals to
idx
equals to n
f
is true
as false
If the child where the key is supposed
to exist has less than T Keys then we
fill that child
so if
C at idx
and
it's less than 3
foreign
idx
now if
flag
and
idx
is greater than n
and C
DX
minus 1.
the move
okay
else
C
idx
remove
okay
return
void B3
node
remove
from leaf
and idx
now we will move all the keys after the
idx position one place backward so for
Loop
end
I is equals to idx Plus 1.
idx plus 1
foreign
should be equals to
at I
and we will reduce the count of keys so
n minus minus
and return
now we will write the function to remove
the idx key from the node which is
non-leaf node so void
heat tree
node
remove
from non-leaf
and
idx
K is equals to
keys at idx
If the child that precedes k at cidx has
at least D Keys then we will find the
predecessor thread of K in the sub tree
rooted at cidx we will replace K by
predecessor recursively and delete
thread in C idx
so if
t i d x
Arrow
and
is greater than equals to
d
then end
equals to get
red
idx
keys
equals to
red
C
idx
remove
d
else
if
C at idx plus 1
Arrow
and
is greater than equals to
t
and end
suck
is equals to
get
suck
idx
of keys at idx
is equals to suck
C at idx plus 1
uses remove
suck
else
will merge
idx
and C at idx
will call remove
foreign
call
remove
return
now we will write a function to get
predecessor of keys idx
to end
B3 node
get prepared
and suck
repeat
end idx
so B tree
node
foreign
is equals to C at idx
while
is not a leaf
then
will be equals to
curve
Arrow C
equal
s n
um
now we will return
key
foreign
Bakery
node
that
suck
int idx
r
ather
equals to C idx
Plus 1.
while
curve
Arrow
is not leave
or
is equals to curve
look at zero
now we will return
now we will write a function to fill
chart C idx which has less than T minus
1 keys
big tree
node
l
and I Rex
if
repeat If the previous child C IDF minus
1 has more than T minus on Keys then we
will borrow a key from that child
so if idx
is not equals to zero
and
see at I idx
-1
calls
n
greater than equals to
t
then we will borrow from priv
DX
else
if
idx is not equals to n
and
C at idx plus 1
calls
and
greater than equals to 1. a t
then
we will borrow
from next
at idx
else
if
idx
is not equals to n
then we will merge
idx
merge
idx minus 1
return
now we will write a function borrow from
prev
ode
star child
is equals to C idx
catering
node
star sibling
is equals to C
idx
-1
now the last key from C idx minus 1 goes
up to the parent and key IDF minus 1
from parent is inserted as the first key
in C ideas thus the losses sibling one
key and child gains one key moving all
keys in cidx one step ahead
so for Loop
and
I
is equals to
child
at an
-1
I greater than equals to zero
and I minus minus
minus minus five
child
called keys
at I plus 1
equals to
child
calls
keys
at I
now if C idx is not a leaf then we will
move all its child pointers one step
ahead
if underscore child
call sleeve
or
and
I equals to child
foreign
equals to zero
I
minus minus I
child
at C bracket I Plus 1.
equals to
child
C bracket I
um
now we will set the child's first key
equal to the key at idx minus 1 from the
current node
so child
is
at zero
is equals to
keys at idx minus 1.
now we will move siblings last child SC
ID access first set
so if
child is not leave
the child
Arrow
C bracket zero
is equals to
sibling
at
C
sibling
calls n
oh
keys at idx minus 1
will be equals to
sibling
keys
false
n minus 1.
now child
at n
will be plus equals to
1.
and sibling
and
will be equals to minus equals to
1.
return
void
B tree
node
from next
time d idx foreign
node
child
request to see at idx
and B tree
node
sibling
is equals to C at idx
plus one
now key idx is inserted as the last key
in the C idx
so child
keys
and
foreign
keys
at idx
now child
at case
X
if
child is not leave
foreign
equals to
sibling
at
C 0.
out the first key from sibling is
inserted into key idx
sub key at idx
is equals to
sibling
keys
zero
or Loop
and
I is equals to 1.
I less than
sibling
at n
plus plus I
sibling
I
minus 1.
okay
is equals to
sibling
now if
sibling is not leave
I
equals to 1.
then equals to Sibling calls n
foreign
C at I minus 1.
equals to
sibling
calls C at I
now we'll be increasing and decreasing
the key count of cidx and cidx plus 1
respectively
so
child
at n
is plus equals to 1.
sibling
calls
n
minus equals to one
return
now void
big tree
node
merge
with argument as end idx
B tree
node
start child
is equals to C
DX
B tree
node
or sibling
equals to C at idx plus 1
foreign
position in cidx
so child
calls keys
T minus one
is equals to
keys
at idx
now we will be copying keys from cidx
plus 1 to cidx at the end so for
four and
I is equals to 0
I less than sibling
equals n
and plus plus I
so child
I plus t
equals to
sibling
I
if
not child
calls leave
for
I is equals to zero
I less than equals to
sibling
calls
S Plus I
child
but see
bracket I plus t
equals to sibling
because
I
now four
and
is equals to idx
Plus 1.
I less than n
plus plus I
I minus 1.
is equals to case at I
or
and
I is equals to
idx plus 2
I less than equals to and
and plus plus I
e
at I minus 1.
is equals to
C
at I
and
plus equals to
sibling
and
plus one
delete
sibling
return
now we will write the mean function that
inserts a new key in this battery
so void
battery
and K
f
root is equals to
null
then we will allocate memory to root
is equals to new
V3 node
T comma true
[Music]
is
record zero
is equals to K
and root
at n
is equals to 1
.
else
foreign
calls
and
is equals to
2 Star
D minus 1.
so B3
node
star s
is equals to
new
B tree
node
e
comma false
now s
C bracket zero
is equals to root
foreign
root
and
I is equals to zero
f
as
keys
bracket zero
less than k
I plus plus
s
C bracket I
insert
noun full
okay
now we will change the root to s
else
root
calls
insert non full at k
a utility function to insert at known
full node
int
I
is equals to n minus 1.
F Leaf equals to true the following Loop
does two things finds the location of
key to be inserted or moves all greater
key to one place ahead so while
I is greater than equals to 0
and
keys
at I
are greater than k
then
case at I plus 1
will be equals to keys at I
and I minus minus
keys
at I plus 1
will be equals to
a
and N will be equals to n Plus 1.
else
while
I is greater than equals to zero
and
is
Hattie
is greater than k
I minus minus
f
C bracket I plus 1
.
equals to
2 Star
T minus 1
.
child
I Plus 1.
okay
comma C
y plus 1
f
is bracket I plus 1
okay
I plus plus
I plus 1
insert non-hole
okay
B3
node
and I
comma
B tree
node
star y
foreign
Bakery node
Starz
is equals to new
B tree
node
argument as y calls T
and Y called slave
now that calls
n equals to
T minus 1.
now we will copy the last T minus 1 case
of Y to Z so for Loop
and J is equals to zero
J less than
T minus 1.
J plus plus
so Z keys
okay
is equals to
y
at keys
J Plus
t
so if
y
if
equals to
false
fourth
and
J is equals to zero
J less than t
J plus plus
G
C bracket I
is equals to
y calls
C bracket J Plus
t
now y calls
n equals to T minus 1
now since this node is going to have a
new child we will create space for the
new child
so for Loop
and
change equals to n
J greater than equals to
I plus 1
J minus minus
C vector
J plus 1
equals to C bracket
J
or C bracket
5 plus 1
is
equals to
C bracket
J
e bracket I plus 1
is equals to Z
now for Loop
and
J is equals to n
minus 1
J greater than equals to
I
J minus minus
is record J
plus 1
equals to
keys at J
is I
equals to
y
is bracket
T minus 1
.
n is equals to n plus one
now we will write function for Traverse
so void
B tree node
Traverse
and I
for Loop
I is equals to zero
I less than n
I plus plus
if
leave
equals to false
and C bracket I
foreign
is equals to false
then c i
will call
Traverse function
now we will write the function to search
key in the sub tree rooted with this
node so B tree
node
star
battery
node
search
and okay
and
I is equals to zero
while
I is less than n
percent
K is greater than keys
bracket I
so I plus plus
now if
is bracket I
is equals to K
then return
this
now if
all right
if
is equals to true
then return
null
otherwise return
C bracket I
calls
search
okay
now we will write the utility function
to remove
so void
E3
remove
and
k
if
not root
and see how
the
B is empty
return
now we will call the reboot repeat now
we will call the remove function for
root so root
cause
remove
okay
now if root has zero Keys then we will
make its first child as a new root if it
has a child otherwise such root as null
so if
root
and
n is equals to
zero
then B 3
node
TMP
equals to root
if
root
leave
fruit
equals to
null
else
root
equals to root
C bracket
zero
and delete
return
foreign
the code for the main block
we will start with the B tree
of order three
good morning
now let's Traverse this created tree
C out
created
tree
now see out
and L
now we will use T dot remove
to remove 5.
now see out
modified
tea tree
after
deleting
five
T dot Traverse
as you can see we have successfully
deleted five from our B tree let's get
back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session first up all the
operations on B tree have time
complexities of log n
next all the leaves must be on the same
level
next elements of B tree are sorted in
ascending order from left to right
finally every node contains one more
pointer than the number of elements of
the node let's get started with what is
a B plus tree
a B plus tree is a special ambulatory
data structure a B plus tree of order M
can have at most M minus when keys and M
children a B plus tree can be used as B
tree with only keys to each node and
with linked leaves to which an
additional level is added at the bottom
now let's discuss some properties of B
plus trees
first up every node in B plus 3 can have
at most M elements next every node
except the root and the leaf node must
have M by two children
next maximum keys for any node is M
minus 1. and at the last minimum keys
for any node is ceiling of M by 2 minus
1. now let's discuss what are the
various operations we can perform on B
plus field we can perform two operations
on a B plus tree
first up insertion second deletion
now let's discuss these in detail
first up insertion
we have to insert an element is in such
a way so that we want disobey any
properties of B plus trees
now let's try this operation in a code
editor
we will start by creating a node to
create a node we need a struct
B plus
tree node
end
star data
B plus
3 node
space star
child PTR
Boolean
leaf
and int and
for the object star root will be equals
to null
star NP pointer
will be equals to null
comma
star X will be equals to none
now we will write a Constructor for it
so B
node
star in it
and
I
and P equals to
new
B plus
tray node
and P Arrow
Tata
is equals to new
space and
bracket 5.
and then p
child
PTR
is equals to new
B plus 3
node
star
bracket
six
and belief
is equals to true
and NP at the N is equals to zero
okay
now we will write a for Loop
I is equals to 0
less than six
I plus plus
NP
child
is equals to
return
Traverse
B plus
node
star B
out
and
I
again afford to
from I equals to 0
to
I less than P at n
I plus plus
P doesn't have leaves
then we will Traverse that child
Traverse
a
child
KTR bracket High
foreign
now we will check these conditions again
for
I at T at n
we will Traverse it again
from p
child
at I
oh
yeah
and
now next function will be used to sort
this
so void
sort
and star p
comma
and
I comma J comma temp
for Loop
a equals to Pi
a less than equals to n
J plus plus
if
P bracket I
better than P bracket J
then
we will swap these two so temp
will store P at I
and then P will replace its value with P
at J
now we will store
the temp value in the P of J
now let's write a function to split this
side and
set
child
e plus
node
star X
comma
and I
and J
I made
B plus 3 node
star np1
comma
star
np3
comma
star y
and B3
is equals to
find it
and P3
f
Phi is equals to -1
mid is equals to
X
DotA
bracket 2
X data bracket two
will be equals to 0.
then X will store n minus minus
P1
is equals to unit
now when P1 leave
will be equals to false
and X Leaf is equals to true
so for Loop
J is equals to 3
J less than 5.
J plus plus
foreign
will be equals to
X
data
and J
P3
child PTR
at J minus 3
is equals to
X at child PTR
bracket J
MP3
n plus plus
X
data bracket J
is equals to zero
now X greater than
n minus minus
another for Loop
from J is equals to zero
with J less than six
at J plus plus rate
X
child PTR
at J
will be stored at null
now np1
data
at zero position
will be equals to Mid
foreign
child PTR
at
np1
on air
will be equals to X
and P1
child
at np1
on N Plus 1.
will be equals to np3
P1
all n plus plus
root is equals to
np1
now else
Y is equals to X
child
video that I
and mid is equals to Y that dot i
at 2
and Y
on data at 2.
is equals to zero
I will store n minus minus
now for Loop
J is equals to 3
.
say less than five
J plus plus
MP3
data
a minus 3
is equals to y
data
a
and P3
and plus plus
y
data
bracket J
is equals zero
y
n minus minus
X
child
at I plus 1
foreign
X at
child PTR
I plus 1
is equals to
np3
return
now we will write a function to insert
into the tree
void
insert
argument as hint a
so end
I comma temp
X is equals to root
if
x equals to null
then root
is equals to
find it
and X will be equals to root
otherwise
f
X is a leaf
and
X at nine repeat and exit and
is equals to 5.
and temp is equals to
let
child
X
comma minus one
X is equal to root
if
a is greater than
X
at I
and
a is less than
X
at data
I plus 1
I plus plus
and break
else
if
a is less than
X at data
zero
then break
else
continue
X is equals to X at
child
at I
else
slide
hex leaf
is false
for Loop
I is equals to zero
when
I is less than x at n
I plus plus
f
a is greater than
X
at data
Phi
and
a is less than
X
and data
I plus 1
I plus plus
break
else
if
a is less than x
DotA
break
foreign
continue
if
X
child
and
is equals to five
then temp is equals to split
child
at X comma I
X
data
at x n on n
is equals to temp
foreign
at n plus plus
continue
else
X is equals to X
child
video
I
X
on data
at
X at n
is equals to A
sort
X at data
okay
foreign
X at n plus plus
now let's write a code for the main
block
first we will declare some variables as
and I
and
and T
now we will request
enter
number of
element
will be inserted
in
pattern
now see out
now we will enter the element so enter
element
now we will write a whole Loop
I is equals to 0 to I less than n
at I plus plus
so c n
T and insert
t
now we will Traverse this tree we'll see
how
thank you
that was
Sun
of B plus 3
.
I was
root
let's execute this
we will enter five elements
2 comma 3 comma 5 comma seven comma 9.
as you can see we have successfully
traversed a first B plus tree
let's get back to our slides
next deletion while deleting any element
from B plus 3 we have to be careful not
to break any properties of B plus tree
like all the leaves must be present at
the same level or elements must be in
ascending order
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
start by creating a B plus tree
first we will declare a global variable
and
Max equals to 3
then we will
create a class
PP tree
and a class
node
Boolean
is leaf
and
star key
comma size
code
PTR
and a friend class
equity
now public
load variable
now we will write class
BP tree
so no
star root
void
insert
internal
end
node star
comma
node
star
void
remove internal
and comma
code
star comma
node star
and a node function
find parent
s
node
.star
public
tree
The Constructor
search function
a insert function
foreign
display
get root
a is equals to new
okay
bracket Max
is equals to
new
node
star
record Max Plus One
BP tree
now void
beep
BP tree
insert
foreign
X
2 is equals to null
then root
is equals to
new node
calls key
at zero
rules at XX
or row
checks
is leave
okay
advice
is equals to 1.
else
node
cursor
is equals to root
node
star parent
while
cursor
is leave
is equals to
false
parent
supposed to cursor
now for Loop
and I is equals to zero
to I less than
cursor
size
I plus plus
f
X is less than cursor
key
at I
cursor
is equals to person
at
PTR
at I
f
I is equals to
cursor
size
minus one
cursor
at
PTR
I plus one
break
now if
person
nice
is less than Max
then end
I is equals to zero
while
X is greater than cursor
e
at I
and
I is less than
cursor
sides
I plus plus
for Loop
and
is equals to
cursor
at size
and J
is greater than I
a minus minus
so cursor
calls key
at J
is equals to
cursor
false key
at J minus 1.
cursor
calls key
at I
is equals to X
person
calls size
calls
PTR
add cursor
size
is equals to
cursor
PTR
at
cursor size
minus 1.
foreign
cursor
PTR
equals
else
node
equals to new
right
virtual
note
Max Plus One
for
end
I equals to zero
two
I less than Max
at the rate I plus plus
virtual node
okay
is equals to
cursor
e
at I
and
I is equals to zero
comma J
while
X is greater than
virtual
or
make it I
I is less than Max
I plus plus
four
int
J is equals to Max
plus one
comma J is greater than
I
G minus minus
virtual
node
J
is equals to
virtual
code
at J minus 1
so virtual
node
at I
is equals to X
it's a new Leaf
is leaf
is equals to true
size
is equals to
Max
plus one
by two
New Leaf
size
is equals to Max
plus one
minus
Max
plus one
divided by 2.
question
do that
protectors
nice
is equals to
New Leaf
a new Leaf
that
New Leaf
is equals to
cursor
PTR
Max
now void
BP tree
insert
internal
ENT X
comma node star
cursor
comma
node
star
child
if
person
nice
is less than Max
then
end
is equals to zero
while
X is greater than
cursor
at
key
that I
and
I just less than
cursor
of size
I plus plus
for Loop
end
J is equals to
cursor size
J is greater than
I
a minus minus
cursor
at Key
h a
is equals to cursor
a minus 1
cursor
okay
is equals to X
cursor
place
Plus
cursor
at PTR
bracket I plus one
is equals to child
else
node
star
to internal
is equals to
new node
print
virtual
key
is Max Plus One
node
star
virtual
key
at maths
plus one
virtual
PTR
at
or
and I
is equal to zero
I less than Max
I plus plus
virtual
key
I
as equals to
cursor
key
for
end
I is equals to zero
I less than Max
plus one
foreign
star
answer
comma node
star child
start parent
if
cursor
is leave
or
cursor
at ATR
zero
yes I think
foreign
return
pattern
else
parent
is equals to find
cursor
PTR
right
if
parent
not equals to
null
return
Ed
had it
now void
EP tray
remove
and X
root
personal
then
see out
empty
else
node
star cursor
first two
star parent
and
sibling
comma
right
sibling
so while
foreign
equals to
false
so for
paint
I is equals to zero
I less than cursor size
and I plus plus
parent is equals to cursor
left sibling
is equals to I minus 1
.
right
sibling
is equals to I Plus 1.
f
X is less than
is
at I
then cursor
will be equals to cursor
PTR
well if
I is equals to
cursor
eyes
minus one
was too high
right sibling
plus 2y Plus 2.
cursor
is equals to
reversar
bracket I plus one
like
more
is equals to
false
for
those
position zero
first
is less than cursor
size
of course
Plus
f
Acer
key
at pause
is equals to X
then found
equals to true
and then pray
now if
not from
then
go
not
if
cursor
size
close to zero
then
Co
right
delete
cursor
presser
video
delete
presser
root
is equals to no
return
foreign
cursor
key
a type
is equals to
write node
cursor
add cursor
size
now see out
merging
to
remove
internal
that
right sibling
minus 1 comma
parent
comma
right node
delete
right
node
okay
right node
right now
foreign
cursor
is not equals to null
for
I equals to one
foreign
C out
yes sir
C out cursor
key
at I
C out
and
if
cursor
this leave
not equals to true
and four
and
I equals to zero
I less than cursor
price
plus one
I plus plus
okay
PTR
download
star BP tree
get root
foreign
now we will write the main block
we will start with an empty tree PP tree
node
Dot
insert
five
node dot insert
note
dot insert
node
dot display
Dot
get through
node
dot remove
D okay
dot display
Dot
truth
let's execute this
as you can see this program is working
flawlessly we have successfully deleted
the key 15. let's get back to our slides
last let's sum up what we have learned
in this session
first up B plus trees are fast at
performing all its operations
next all the leaves must be present on
the same level and data is only stored
in leaf node
next elements of the B plus tree are
sorted in ascending order from the left
to the right
finally every node contains one more
pointer than the number of elements of
the node
let's try to understand what is a bubble
sort algorithm the bubble sort algorithm
is one of the fundamental and simplest
forms of algorithm used to sort a
collection of elements the collection of
elements can be either a set of numbers
or characters the control iterates
through a sequence of numeric or
character type elements in the bubble
sort algorithm and rearranges them into
ascending or descending order
the bubble sort algorithm rearranges one
element at a time the bubble sort
algorithm is also known as the sinking
algorithm
here we have some random distributed
Elements which are 30 10 20 50 and 40
and after performing the bubble sort
algorithm all the elements are sorted as
10 20 40 and 50. so how is it done
we will see in the next segment where we
will understand the working
terminologies of bubble set algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm will not get
implemented on the entire array in one
group instead it Compares two adjacent
passive elements in an array if the
elements are not in the correct order
then they are swapped so the largest of
the two moves towards the right and this
process continues until the most
significant element or bubble is moved
towards the highest position after the
first process is finished the search for
the next most significant object starts
and the swapping continues until the
whole array is in correct order this
process is employed when you want to
arrange the elements in ascending order
to understand the logic in a better way
let's go through an example
the example on my screen consists of
five elements according to the bubble
sort algorithm logic we need four
iterations to sort all the elements in
the ascending order or in descending
order the elements in the array are as
follows they are 3 8 4 2 and 12. so in
this array the index begins with 0 and
ends with 4. and this time the bubble
sort algorithm goes through the data
element list and it is known as a pass
let us analyze the total number of
comparisons required to sort the array
in the correct order according to the
formula
if n is the total number of elements in
an array then the total number of
comparisons needed to sort the entire
array can be calculated by a simple
formula shown on my screen that is n is
equals to n minus 1. so in this scenario
we need 5 minus 1 that is 4 comparisons
or passes to sort the entire array in
the first pass there are four steps
let us select the first two elements
that is 3 and 8. according to the
requirement we need to sort this array
in the ascending order hence when we
compare 3 and 8 clearly we get 3 as the
least number so we do not need to swap
them next is the step two comparing the
second and third Elements which are
eight and four here we need to swap
these two elements because 8 is always
greater than 4 and it requires placing
the elements in the ascending order now
moving ahead we have step 3 moving on to
the third and fourth Elements which are
8 and 2 and here again we need to swap 8
a width 2 because 8 is greater than 2.
and in the step 4 we have we have the
last Elements which are 8 and 12. there
is no need to swap because 8 is already
less than 12 so you can see it clearly
so now we enter into past two and in
past two we need three steps so the
first step in the second pass let us
select the first two elements which are
three and four
no swapping is necessary as they are
already in order next we have step two
in Step 2 we need to select the elements
2 and 4. as you can see 2 is always less
than 4 so there is no swapping required
next we have step three in step 3 we
need to compare the elements 4 and 8 and
here we may not need any switching
because 4 is already less than 8. now
here you can see that we are not
comparing 8 and 12 because the last
element is already sorted now we have
come to the last pass and here there is
only one step the step is to compare the
first two elements two and three and
then swap them as 3 is greater than 2.
now the array is finally sorted and we
do not need to do any more comparisons
after understanding the working process
of the bubble sort algorithm we will see
its pseudocode in the pseudocode there
is a function named as bubble sort the
bubble sort function includes an array
of collections of sortable elements let
us consider n as the length of the array
after that we have to repeat comparisons
for the first element to the last
element of the array if the first
element is greater than its next
consecutive element then we must swap
both the elements and place them
correctly we do not need a switch after
closing this repeated statement and
getting out of the loop this bubble sort
function will end after understanding
the pseudocode of the bubble sort
algorithm let's learn about the
optimized bubble sort algorithm so we
can optimize the algorithms in a loop by
programming it to avoid the comparison
at n minus 1 position after every
iteration since the nth element is
already sorted in the previous iteration
more generally more than one element may
be placed in their final position on a
single pass all the elements after the
last swap are sorted in every pass and
do not need to be rechecked optimized
bubble sort algorithm allows skipping
over many elements this results in a
worst case that is 50 Improvement in
comparison count and adds little
complexity because of the new code
substance the swapped variable
next we will learn variations of the
bubble sort algorithm so there are two
variations of the bubble sort algorithm
they are odd even sort and cocktail
shaker so odd even sort is a parallel
version of bubble sort for the message
passing system whereas cocktail shaker
is a sort of bi-directional bubble sort
that first goes from beginning to the
end and ends to the beginning after
knowing the variation of the bubble sort
algorithm now we will see the complexity
of bubble sort algorithm so the best
case of the bubble subtle algorithm is
Big O of n where n is the number of
elements being sorted and worst and
average cases of the bubble set
algorithm are Big O of n into n and
lastly the space complexity of the
bubble Circle algorithm is Big of 1.
here n is the number of data elements
being sorted let us understand when this
complexity occurs the best case of
bubble sort algorithm is O of n which
occurs at all the data elements in an
array are already sorted here we have an
example with some data elements in an
array which are already sorted that is
10 20 30 40 and 50. next talking about
the average and worst case the worst
case an average case of the bubble set
algorithm is O of n to the power 2 that
is N squared or n into n it occurs when
all the data elements in an array are
reversely sorted again we have an
example that consists of data elements
that are reversely sorted that are 50 40
30 20 and 10 in the narrative lastly we
have space complexity the space
complexity of bubble sort algorithm as o
of 1 because only one additional
variable is required to implement
bubbles or algorithm whereas temporary
variable we came to the last topic where
we will understand four main
applications of bubbles or algorithm
first application of bubble sort
algorithm states that this sorting
technique is used to sort the elements
in a specific order the bubble sort
algorithm uses less storage and is the
second application of bubble sort
algorithm third the real life
application states that the bubble sort
algorithm is used to start the students
based on their height in the line
lastly bubble sort is used to create a
stack pile up the elements based on
their height after covering all the
bubble sort algorithm topics we will now
see a practical demonstration of bubble
sort algorithm now on my screen we have
an example for bubble sort algorithm so
let us get started with the code in this
code at the first position we have some
header files that is standard input
output standard Library Etc after that
we will Define the main function in the
main function we will declare an array
with maximum size of 50. so here you can
see that we have the first array
variable that size is 50. size will be
defined with declaration only because we
cannot change the array size in the
runtime after that we will declare 4
variables that is a b num and temp
non-variable will store the number of
elements of an array after that we will
ask the user how many elements are
required for the array using printf
function
so here is the printer function where we
will be asking the user to enter the
number of elements in an array and the
user will enter the elements and this
will be done using scanf function then
finally we will print all the elements
that the user wants to store in an array
using another printf function we will
have three Loops firstly there will be a
loop from the first element to the last
element of the array so this is the
first for Loop you need then second the
for Loop will use the variable a for the
rotation purpose as we know rotation
equal to number of elements minus 1 so
it will make a loop from index 0 to
number minus 1.
the last Loop is used for how many
passes will be required for the
implementation and we already pass
equally to the number of elements minus
number of rotations minus 1. so there is
the loop from index 0 to number minus a
minus 1 then there will be the if
condition stating that if the first
element of an array at index B is
greater than the element at the index B
plus 1 then we will make swap then we
will come out of the loop and we will
print all the array elements after
performing the bubble sort algorithm now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed now let us enter
the number of elements let me choose 5.
now let us enter the elements in a
random order
so this was the array input 3 2 4 1 and
5 and here after executing the bubble
sort algorithm we have this sorted array
that is one two three four and five
let's get started with an introduction
to insertion sort insertion sort is
basically a sorting algorithm in which
each item in the final sorted array is
sorted one at a time and it is
significantly less sufficient than more
sophisticated algorithms like quick sort
heapsort or merge sort on larger data
sets
now let's discuss the algorithm of
insertion sort
let's say we have an array
we will start with traversing the array
from index 1 to n minus 1. while
traversing we will compare elements at
the current index to its predecessor if
the data at the current index is smaller
than its predecessor then we will
compare it with the element before that
after that we will shift bigger elements
to an index up to make space for swapped
elements
then we will shift the bigger elements
to an index up to make space for the
swapped element and then we will iterate
the same steps again to sort the
complete array
we have now introduced the incision sort
and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start with creating a function
to sort an array using session sort so
void
insertion sort
we will give it argument as end array
ARR
comma int size
we will declare variables and I
comma key
comma J
now
we will create a loop for Loop
from I is equals to 1
to I less than size
I plus plus
here we are traversing this array from
index 1 to the size n minus 1.
so e
is equals to
ARR at I
and J is equals to I minus 1.
now we will move the elements of ARR 0
to I minus 1 that are greater than the
key to one position ahead of the current
position
so while
J
is greater than equals to
and
ARR at J is greater than key
then we will swap these so air
at J plus 1
is equals to ARR
at J
and J will be equals to J minus 1.
and then we will assign ARR J plus 1
is equals to key
now we will write a function to print
this array of size
void
print
array
we will give its argument as end array
and
size size
we will declare int I is equals to zero
or Loop
I is equals to 0
I
less than size
I plus plus
Co
ARR
bracket I
and C out
and
now we will write the main block
so end
ARR
is equals to
12 comma 11 comma 15 comma
9 comma 6 comma 7.
and
size is equals to we will find the size
using size of so size is equals to
size of
ARR
divided by size of
ARR at index 0.
now we will print this array without
sorting so see how
unsorted array
and we will print
array
error comma size
now we will call insertion sort
size
C out
we will print this
array
reported
now we will again call Print
array
argument as ARR comma size
now let's print this
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly it has sorted this array
let's get started with an introduction
to selection sort
the selection sort algorithm is an in
place comparison based method that
divides the list into two halves with
the sorted portion on the left and the
unsorted half on the right
then the smallest element from the
unsorted array is chosen and swapped
with the leftmost element and that
element is added to the sorted array now
let's discuss the selection sort
algorithm let's say we have an array
first we will divide this array into sub
arrays unsorted array and sorted array
then we will divide the minimum element
from the unsorted array and swap it with
the leftmost element of this unsorted
array after that we will add it to the
unsorted array
we will keep repeating this process
until there are no elements left on the
unsorted array
we have now introduced selection sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
argument will be integer pointer X comma
integer pointer
by
we will declare an element them
to store the value of pointer X
then we will store pointer wise value in
x
and we will store times value in y
and that's how we can swap them
next we will write the definition of
selection sort function
void
selection sort
argument will be int array ARR
comma
and n
we will declare variables and I J and a
Min underscore idx variable to store the
minimum index
now we will one by one move boundaries
of unsorted sub arrays so for Loop
I is equals to 0
where I is less than n minus 1
I plus plus
we will find the minimum element in this
unsorted array so min
underscore idx
is equals to I
of 4
is equals to
I plus 1
J less than n
J plus plus
if
error element at jth location
is less than
array at the Min index
then
Min idx will be updated with j
now we will swap the for minimum element
with the first element
so
we will call swap function
with argument as
10 percent
ARR
admin idx
comma
10 percent
ARR at ith location
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
and
early
argument as and ARR
and its size
and n
or do
and I is equals to 0
I less than
and
I plus plus
V out
ARR at I
out
and
now we will write the code for the main
block
so int
ARR
is equals to
4 comma 2 comma 1 comma 8 comma 3
you will find the size of this array so
end n is equals to
size of
array ARR
divided by
size of
this arrays first element
now we will call selection sort function
argument as ARR comma n
then we will try to print this so see
out
sorted
array
and we will call the function print
array to print this array
ARR comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using selection sort
algorithm
let's get back to our slides let's get
started with what is a binary Heap
it's a complete binary tree with all
levels completely filled except the last
level where all leaves are to the left
as far as possible
binary Heap can be either Min heat or
Max Heat
in a Min binary Heap the elements at
root must be minimum among all elements
present in the binary Heap
Max binary Heap is like minhip where
root must be maximum among all elements
now let's discuss implementation of Heap
Sort
first we will start with creating a Max
heap of elements present
next up we will remove the elements at
the root and put it at the end of the
array and put the smallest element at
the root
after that we will reduce the height by
1.
finally we will helpify the root element
again and repeat the process from step
2. now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor we will
start by creating a function to amplify
a sub tree rooted with node I which is
an index in Array ARR and N is the size
of the Heap so void
ep5
and
ARR
comma
and n
comma end
I
now we will initialize largest as root
so end
largest
is equals to I
now we will Define the left and the
right subtree so end
L is equals to
2 into I plus 1
and end R is equals to
multiply with I
plus 2
now if the left child is larger than
root then if
L is less than n
and
ARR at l
error at L is greater than ARR at
largest
so
the largest
will be equals to l
now if
right child is larger than the largest
so far
so if
R is less than n
and
error at r
is greater than ARR at largest
so largest
is equals to R
now if largest is not root so if
largest
is not equals to I
we will swap
ARR
at I
width
a ARR
at largest
and then we will recursively call ep5
for the affected subtree
AR comma and
comma largest
now we will write the mean function to
do Heap Sort so void
keep sort
ARR
[Music]
breaker comma
and
now we will start by building Heap so
for
and
I is equals to
n by 2
minus 1
where I is greater than equals to 0
at I minus minus
we will call heapify
for ARR comma n comma I
now we will one by one extract an
element from the Heap so four
and I
is equals to n minus 1.
where I is greater than 0
at I minus minus
now we will move current route to end so
swap
error at zero
to ARR
at I
and we will call Max cpify on the
reduced Heap so he P5
error
comma I
comma
zero
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
and array
and
ARR
comma and n
so for
and I is equals to 0
I less than n
plus plus I
we will do c out
error
bracket I
is
and a c out
and L
now let's type the code for the main
block
so
and
ARR
is equals to
e comma
18 comma 12. comma
14 comma 5 comma 6. comma to
now we will write a statement to find
the size of this array so end
and it's equals to
size of
ARR
divided by
size of
the first element of the array arr0
now we will call Heap Sort function so
heat sort
or ARR
comma n
now let's print this
array so C out
sorted
array is
print
array
at error comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see our sorting function is
working flawlessly
now let's get back to our slides till
now we have discussed the binary Heap
and the algorithm of Heap Sort now let's
discuss some applications of Heap Sort
first up
it can be used to sort a nearly sorted
series of data next it can be used to
find minimum or maximum elements of the
series with ease also it can be used to
solve problems which requires some sort
of priority let's get started with what
exactly is divide and conquer algorithm
a divide and conquer algorithm
iteratively divides a problem into two
or more sub problems of the same or
relative type until they are simple
enough to be sold directly the sub
problem Solutions are then integrated to
solve the original problem
there are three steps involved in the
divide and conquer principle that is
divide conquer and combine the first
step is to divide the significant
problem into smaller sub problems
the second phase is to conquer the
solutions to all divided sub problems
then the final step is to combine and
merge all of the solutions to create a
definite solution
we will understand this by an example
right here on my screen
suppose we have a large problem we can
use divide and conquer technique to
divide it into n number of sub problems
such as problem 1 problem 2 problem 3
problem 4 and so on until we reach the
problem n
then we conquer all the solutions to the
specified sub problems as solution 1 2 3
4 and so on and finally we merge all the
solutions to get one definitive solution
now that was divide and conquer
algorithm followed by that let us get
into much sort algorithms so merge sort
is one of the most efficient sorting
algorithms it is based on divide and
conquer strategy merch or continuously
divides a list into numerous sublists
until each sub list contains only one
entry then merges all those sub lists
into a sorted list
there are four elements on my screen we
have 7 and 3 in the left half and five
and two in the right half after dividing
the four elements in half we combined
all the items in ascending order that is
2 3 5 and 7.
in the next segment we are going to
understand how it happened and we are
going to learn the working procedure of
merge sort algorithm
there are two approaches to implement
the merge sort algorithm the first
method is top down approach and the
second method is bottoms up approach the
first method that is the top done
approach implies that it begins with the
large picture from then it's broken into
smaller chunks now the second method
that is the bottom up technique which
starts with a specific number of jobs
and works its way up to the general
let's have a look at how to implement
the merge sort algorithm using top-down
approach the top down merge sort
approach is the methodology that uses a
recursion mechanism it starts at the top
and proceeds downwards splitting the
array into two halves making a recursive
call and merging the results until one
gets to the bottom of the array for a
better understanding of the top down
approach method
consider the following scenario right
here on my screen we have an example of
an array of size 6 consisting of
elements
73956 and 4. starting with 0 and ending
with 5. using the following formula
we'll divide the array by its middle
that is Middle is equals to left plus
right divided by 2.
we have three elements on the left and
three elements on the right near the
middle so according to the drop down
strategy we divide the given array in
half resulting in three elements that is
7 3 and 9 on the left and 5 6 1 4 on the
right next we sort all these elements in
ascending order by doing so the first
half will be 3 7 and 9 and the right
half will be four five and six and after
merging all of them we will have the
sorted array that is three four five six
and nine
next we will understand the bottoms up
approach
an iterative process is used in Bottoms
Up merge sort approach it starts with a
single element array and then joins two
neighboring items while also sorting
them the combined sorted arrays are
combined and sorted again only until one
single unit of the sorted array elements
remains
now let us look at an example right here
on my screen in the first iteration we
will merge pairs of array sizes by 1
sorting each of the two elements when
you iterate the array by size 1 the
elements 7 and 3 become 3 and 7.
similarly 9 and 5 become 5 and 9 and
finally 6 and 4 become 4 and 6.
we will merge the pairs of array size by
2 in the next iteration with the bottoms
up method as a result the elements 3 7
and 5 will become 3 5 and 7 and the same
way 9 4 and 6 will become 4 6 and 9. in
the last iteration merge pairs of array
size by 3 so that after sorting three
five seven four six and nine becomes 3 4
5 6 and 7 as sorted arrays after
understanding the working procedure of
merge certain algorithm we will now see
the pseudocode of Mercer algorithm
we have a function called merge sort in
this pseudo code and parameter of the
function contains an array named as
array and two variables named as left
and right
if the number of elements in the left is
greater than the number of elements on
the right we will get a middle using
formula left plus right divided by 2.
the merge sort is called and this
function now has an array a left
variable and right variable by calling
merge sort we have array left as middle
plus 1 and right variable and finally by
calling merge sort we have left middle
and right variables in our upcoming
segment we will implement the merge sort
method in a practical demonstration
in the next section we will discuss the
complexity of merge sort algorithm
first we will look into the time
complexity of merge sort algorithm as we
all know time complexity in data
structures is divided into best case
average case and worst case the best
case of North sort algorithm is Big O of
n into log n average case of Muscle
algorithm is Big O of n into log n and
the worst case of Merced algorithm is
Big O of n into log n
the number of elements being sorted is
given by n merge sorts time complexity
is Big O of n star lot n in all three
situations that has worst average and
best because it always divides the area
into two halves and merges the two
halves in linear time it takes up the
same amount of space as the unsorted
array as a result it is not a good idea
to use it to search big unsorted arrays
moving on to the space complexity of the
immersed algorithm this phase complexity
of the merge sort algorithm is large o
of n
in the master algorithm we store the
left and right parts of the merged array
in the temporary arrays and then utilize
the original array to keep the entire
merged array in the worst case scenario
the left and the right sub arrays will
each be n by 2 in size and then the
total auxiliary space will be Big O of n
resulting in a space complexity of Big O
of n following that we will look into
several applications of the merge sort
algorithm so the first application is
merge sort is an efficient way to sort
linked list in Big O of n log n time
subsequent application of the merge sort
algorithm is full linked lists merge
sort implemented without taking up more
space followed by that the Mozart method
is used to count the number of
inversions in a list last application
states that in internal sorting the
merge sort is employed
now let us look into some of the
drawbacks of Mozart algorithm
so some of the drawbacks of Mozart
algorithm are for smaller assignments
Mozart algorithm is slower than the
other sorting algorithms for temporary
array the mods or technique requires an
additional memory space that is space of
Big O of n now let's look into a
practical demonstration of merge sort
algorithm on my screen we have an
example for merge sort algorithm
to Define constants or microsubstitution
we use the hash defined as preprocessor
directive with a constant variable Max
of 10. following that 2 arrays array 1
and array 2 are declared we declare
array 1 and initialize it with elements
like 8 4 7 6 2 3 5 9 10 4 and 1.
array 2 is used for temporary array then
to implement the merge sort concept we
declare a merge sort function we specify
three variables in this function
parameter that is left right and middle
the left variable is used to display the
left part of the array 1 the right
variable is used to display the right
part of the array 1 and middle variable
is used to indicate the middle or center
of the array in this function we utilize
the for Loop in this function setting
the left to level 1 the middle plus 1 to
level 2 and the left to variable I with
the condition that level 2 is less than
or equal to the middle and level 2
should be less than or equal to the
right of the array we have a condition
in this for Loop that if level 1 of
array 1 is less than or equal to level 2
of array 1 we will initialize all the
consecutive elements of level 1 of array
1 to array 2 else we will initialize all
the successive elements of level 2 of
array 1 to array 2.
out of for Loop all subsequent elements
of level 1 of array 1 will be
initialized to add A2 until Level 1 is
less than or equal to the middle all
successive elements of level 2 of array
1 will be initialized to array 2 until
Level 2 is less than or equal to the
right of the array using the loop which
will run from I equal to the left of I
is less than or equal to right we
initialize all the items of array 2 to
array 1. we have declared one more
function in this code namely sorting out
of the merging sort function in which
only the left and right variables are
defined May specify the middle function
in the Sorting function with the
condition that if the left is less than
the right the middle will be calculated
as left plus right divided by 2 then we
call the Sorting function passing left
as middle as right and then another
sorting function passing left as middle
plus 1 and right
finally we use the merge sort function
passing left middle and right to the
Sorting array 1 otherwise we would
return nothing
we entered the main function out of the
Sorting function where we declared the
counter variable I and printed the array
before sorting using the printf function
in follow where I will run from index 0
to the arrays maximum size after that we
invoke sorting method
passing left as 0 index number and right
as the IRS maximum value finally after
doing the merge or process we will print
the array using the printf function and
for Loop we will run from 0 to the RS
maximum value then we compile the
program and run it
now let's try to quickly execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the list
before sorting is eight seven six two
three five nine ten four and one and the
list after sorting is one two three four
four five six seven eight nine and ten
let's get started with an introduction
to quick sort quick sort is a highly
efficient sorting algorithm and it is
based on partitioning an array into
smaller sub arrays and then we will sort
these two resulting sub arrays in the
same manner
this algorithm is quite efficient for
large size data sets as its average and
worst case complexities are bigger of n
Square
now let's discuss algorithm of quick
sort
let's say we have an array first we have
to select a pivot we can select either
the first element or the last or medium
or any random element as pivots this
pivot will dissect the array into two
sub arrays then we will shift all
smaller elements then the pivot element
to the left
then we will again apply the same
operation for the left sub array and
take pivot like we did for the main
array
we'll perform the same for the right sub
array as well
we have now introduced the quick sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
so void swap
end star X
comma and
star y
and
equals to
star X
star X is equals to Star y
r y is equals to temp
now we'll write a function which will
partition this array this function will
take the last element as pivot
and the pivot element at its correct
position in sorted array and places all
smaller elements to the left of the
pivot and all greater elements to the
right of the pivot
so int
partition
int ARR
comma
and
low
comma and I
so end
favorite
equals to
ARR High
now end
I is equals to
row minus 1.
so forth
and
J is equals to low
J less than equals to high minus 1.
a plus plus
now if current element is smaller than
the pivot so if
ARR at J
is less than pivot
then we will increment the I
then we will swap
am percent array
I
comma
Ampersand array
at J
then we will swap
am percent
array
at I plus 1
comma
ampersand array
at High
and then we will return
I Plus 1.
now we will write the mean function that
implements quick sort
so avoid
quick sort
and ARR bracket
comma and low
comma and I
so if
o
is less than High
end
p i is equals to Partition
ARR comma low comma
hi
now we will separately sort elements
before partition and after partition so
quick sort
ARR comma
low
comma
Pi minus 1.
and
quick sort
era
comma
p i plus 1
comma I
now we will write a function to print
this array so void
and array
and ARR
comma
and
size
and I
so for Loop
I is equals to zero
I less than size
a plus plus
C out
array at I
payout
and
now we will write the main block so end
array
n comma 7
comma 8
now we will find the size so int n
is equals to
size of
array
is divided by
size of
array
element at zero
now we will call quick sort
for array
comma 0 comma
n minus 1.
now we will print this so C out
or third
array
a print
ARR command
now let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted our array in this session we will
be discussing the bucket sort algorithm
in data structures
so the buckets are algorithm divides the
unsorted array into several groups known
as buckets so each bucket is sorted
using any suitable sorting algorithm or
recursively applying the same pocket
sort algorithm I know it it's a little
complicated to understand so let's go
through an example
so on my screen we have an example of an
array consisting of numerical elements
that is 12 6 37 29 11 35 21 and 22.
now we will create some buckets with
different ranges
so here we have different buckets
ranging from 0 to 7
8 to 15 16 to 23 24 to 31 and finally
the last bucket width Range 32 to 39 so
6 will be stored in the first packet
followed by that 11 and 12 will be
stored in the second bucket followed by
that we have 21 and 22 stored in the
third bucket followed by that we have 29
in the fourth bucket and finally the
last two elements which are 37 and 35
stored in the last bucket
in the next stage all the elements
elements are sorted according to an
order that might be ascending or
descending in our case we have the
ascending order so the final result will
be 6 11 12 21 22 29 35 and 37.
so this is how the bucket sort algorithm
Works in real time now the next topic
that is working off a bucket sword
algorithm in a detailed way
so now we know the briefing of a bucket
algorithm now let's learn the working of
pocket sort algorithm in depth
suppose we have an array consisting of
decimal values or floating values as the
input so the first element is 0.47 next
we have 0.39
0.23
0.55
0.29 0.41 0.59 and finally 0.31
then we will create an array of size 10
and store 0 in each block
and each block of an array is used as a
bucket for sorting the elements next we
have step 2. insert the elements into
buckets from the array and all elements
are inserted as per the range of the
bucket
buckets ranging from 0 to 1 1 to 2 2 to
3 up to n minus 1 to n here n is the
number of elements in an array so for
our example 0.23 will be multiplied by
10 which is the size of an array and
that gives us 2.3 approximately equal to
2 so finally we will insert 0.23 into
the bucket number 2.
in exact we will insert other elements
into other respective buckets
followed by that we have step 3.
elements of each bucket are sorted using
the stable sorting algorithms
and finally the step four in Step 4 all
the sorted elements of each bucket will
be gathered and represented in the form
of an array as pseudocode is an informal
programming description that does not
require any strict programming language
syntax similarly we will understand it
effortlessly so in the pseudo code first
we will create n empty packets
next we will insert all the array
elements into buckets by multiplying the
size of an array we have to keep doing
this for every array element as we
understood this in working of the packet
sort algorithm after that we have to
sort individual buckets using insertion
sort and finally we will concatenate all
the sorted packets next we will learn
about the complexities of bucket sort
algorithm first we will see about time
complexity
so talking about the time complexity we
usually have three cases to summarize
the time complexity so first we have the
best case
so that the best case is O of n plus K
next we have the average case that is O
of n into n and finally we have the
worst case that is O of n
here n is the total number of elements
to be sorted and K is the number of
buckets
so let us understand all the three cases
one by one so first we have the best
case
so the best case occurs when all the
elements are uniformly distributed in
the packet with an equal number of
elements in each bucket if insertion
sort is used to sort the bucket sort
algorithm then overall time complexity
is O of n plus k
o of n complexity is for making the
packets and O of K complexity is for
sorting all the elements after
understanding the best case now we will
see how the worst case occurs in the
bucket sort algorithm
the worst case occurs when there are
elements of close range in the array
they are likely to be placed in the same
bucket it makes the complexity depend on
the Sorting algorithm used to sort the
elements of the packets complexity
becomes worse when all the elements are
in reverse order and if insertion sort
is used for sorting then time complexity
becomes o of n into n and lastly we will
learn how the average case occurs in a
bucket sort algorithm the average case
occurs when the elements are randomly
distributed in the array it occurs even
when the elements are distributed in
uniform way bucket sorts run at the
linear time the average case holds true
until the sum of bucket sort sizes is
linear and in the total number of
elements
next we will see about the space
complexity so the space complexity of
all the buckets or algorithms is O of n
plus k
lastly we have stability so talking
about stability so yes the bucket sort
algorithm is stable
after understanding the complexity of
packet sort algorithm now we will
compare the bucket sort algorithm with
other algorithms
so first we will compare the counting
sort algorithm buckets out can be worked
as a generalization of counting sort
algorithm and if each bucket has size 1
then the packets are degenerates to
Counting zero
the variable size of buckets or
algorithm allows it to use o of n memory
instead of O of M memory where m stands
for the distinct value that gives
counting sort o of n plus 1 worst case
Behavior
next we will compare the buckets of
algorithm with quick sort
bucket sort with two buckets is a
practical version of the quick sort
where the pivot value always selects the
median value of the value range another
meaning of choosing the pivot in quick
sort such as a randomly selected period
makes it more resistant to clustering it
in the input distribution
after that we have the merge sort
algorithm starts by Distributing the
list into N Sub list and sorting each
one then the sub list created by merge
sort have overlapping ranges and cannot
be recombined by a simple concatenation
bucket sort lastly we have one more
sorting algorithm that is Radix sort for
comparison top down Radix sort can be a
particular case of bucket sort where
both range of values and the number of
packets has contained the power of 2.
this approach can accelerate these cater
phase since we only need to examine each
element's prefix of bit representation
to determine a bucket
at last we have one more topic to learn
that is the applications of packets or
algorithm
the bucket sort algorithm consists of
two main applications
first by using bucket sort algorithm
input is uniformly distributed on the
Range and second by using packets or
algorithm there are floating Point
values
now let us go through a practical
demonstration of bucket sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
pocket sword algorithm so we will begin
with the header files followed by that
we will Define a function namely bucket
sort algo
this particular function is to implement
a bucket sort algorithm in the functions
argument there will be an array namely
ARR and a variable num which will store
the number of elements in an array after
that we will Define two counter
variables which are I and J and declare
one more array namely array 1 with the
same size of an ARR AR re
so this particular second array will be
used for displaying all the elements in
the array 1 we will have a for Loop
which will run from index 0 to the
entire size of an array and for this
array we will use the variable I as the
counter variable
we will have another for Loop to print
all the repeated numbers with frequency
in an array we will run another follow
from index 0 to the last element of both
the arrays and elements of array and
array 1 will assign to ARR array now we
will accept from both the loops and now
we will enter into the main function
where we will declare an array namely
array with the size of 100 and two
variables which are num and I next we
will ask the user to enter several
elements of an array using printf
function and now the user will enter
number of elements and we will scan that
using this kind of function now we will
ask the user to enter the elements of an
array using printf function and the
entered elements will be scanned using
the scanf function and next we will
print a before sorting and an array
after sorting using for Loops by calling
the packets of algo function and in this
function we will pass the name of an
array that is an array and the size of
an array that is num
no
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed now let us try to
enter the number of elements that is 5.
now let us enter all the five elements
2 3
1 4 and 5.
so the array before sorting was two
three one and four five then the array
got sort using packet sort algorithm and
the resultant array is one two three
four and five in ascending order in this
session we will discuss the counting
sort algorithm
so without any further Ado let's get
started with an introduction to Counting
sort
counting sort is a sorting algorithm
that sorts the elements of an array by
counting the number of occurrence of
each unique element in the array the
count is stored in an auxiliary array
and the Sorting is done by mapping the
count as an index of that auxiliary
array
now let's discuss the counting sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array first we will
find the largest element in this array
to evaluate the range of the elements
then we will create a count array to
store the count of element from the
array
then we will update the count arrays
element with a cumulative count
at last we will output each element from
the array followed by decreasing its
count by 1.
we have now introduced the counting sort
and its algorithm now let's try to
implement this algorithm in the code
editor
let's start by creating a consort
function void
count sort
its argument as int ARR
comma and n
we will declare an array output
size 10
and an array count
again with the size 10.
and an integer variable Max
is equals to ARR at zero
now we will write a for Loop to find the
largest element of this array
so for
and I is equals to 1.
I less than n
I plus plus
if
ARR at I
is greater than Max
and Max
will be equals to ARR at I
now we will initialize the count array
with all zeros so 4
and I is equals to 0
to I less than equals to Max
plus I
count at I is equals to 0.
now we will store the count of each
element in this array so for Loop
and
I is equals to 0
I less than n
I plus plus
count
at ARR bracket I
is plus plus
now we will write a for Loop to store
the cumulative count of each array so
for
and I is equals to 1.
where I is less than equals to Max
at I plus plus
count
at I
is equals to
plus equals to
count
I minus 1.
now we will find the index of each
element of the original array in count
array and place the elements in the
output array
so far
and I is equals to n
minus 1
I greater than equals to 0
I minus minus
so output
account
at ARR I
minus
1.
is equals to
ARR at I
and then we will decrease count
ARR I
by one
now let's write a function to print this
array so avoid
print array
end they are breaker
comma and and
so for Loop
and I is equals to zero
I less than n
I plus plus
C out
error at I
doubt
handle
now let's write the main block
and
ARR
is equals to
we will write the element
now let's find out the size of this
array so end n is equals to
size of
array divided by
that is first element
now we will call the consort function
ARR comma and
now we will print this array so print
array
ARR comma n
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using counting sort
let's get started with an introduction
to Radix sort
Radix sort is a non-comparative sorting
algorithm it avoids comparison by
creating and distributing elements into
buckets according to their Radix
and for elements with more than one
significant digit this bucketing process
is repeated for each digit while
preserving
The Ordering of the prior step until all
digits have been considered
now let's discuss Red X sort algorithm
let's say we have an array first we will
find the largest element in the array to
decide maximum number of significant
digits we will need to compare to sort
this array we will go through each
significant place and sort the array one
by one
first we will solve the array according
to the units please
then we will sort according to the tens
place
and then we will sort according to
hundreds place and so on till the array
is sorted
we have now introduced the Red X sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code reader
we will start with the utility function
to get maximum value in this array so
hint
get Max
with an argument as array ARR
comma size n
we will declare variable int MX is
equals to ARR at 0. and we will write a
for Loop
where
and I is equals to 1.
2 I less than n
at I plus plus
I
is greater than MX
then
MX will be equals to ARR
at I
and then we will return
the value of MX
now we will write a function to do
counting sort of array ARR according to
the digits represented by exponent
so void
down sort
at end ARR
comma
and N comma
and EXP
we will declare an integer array output
and I comma account array
of size 10.
where all elements are zero
now we will store the count of all the
elements of the array ARR
so for Loop
I is equals to 0
I less than n
to I plus plus
count
error
and I
divided by EXP
modulus of
10.
plus plus
now we will change count I so that count
I now contain actual position of this
digit in output
so for
I is equals to 1
I less than 10.
I plus plus
count
I
plus equals to
count
I minus 1.
now we will build the output array
so for Loop
at I is equals to n minus 1. 2 I greater
than equals to 0
and I minus minus
output
count
ARR at I
divided by EXP
modulus
10.
minus 1.
is equals to
ARR at I
and now
foreign
divided by EXP
modular
10.
minus minus
now we will copy the output array of ARR
so that ARR now contains sorted numbers
according to the current digit
so for
I is equals to 0
I less than n
I plus plus
ARR
at I
is equals to
output
now let's write the main function that
will sort the ARR using Redix sort
so void
vertex sort
and error
comma
and and
m is equals to
at Max
ARR comma n
now we will do the counting sort for
every digit note that instead of passing
digit number exp is passed exp is
basically 10 raised to the power I where
I is current digit number so
or
end
EXP
is equals to 1.
and M divided by
EXP
is greater than zero
while EXP
ired equals to
10.
we will do count sort
on ARR
of size n
with the XP
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
and array
and ARR
comma
and and
for
and I is equals to 0
I less than n
I plus plus
a out
array
at I
now let's write the main function
we will declare end ARR
bracket
with values
170 comma 45 comma 75
comma 90 comma
eight zero two comma 24
comma 2 comma 66
now we will find out the size of this
array ARR
and is equals to size of
ARR divided by
size of
ARR first element
now we will call the Red X sort function
and we will print this array
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using Red X sort
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up Red X sort can be used on
lexographically sortable data next up
Redix sort utilizes the count sort
algorithm
next Radix sort is done by sorting
elements using significant digits
finally Redix sort consumes more memory
space than quick sort so what exactly is
a graph so a graph is a data structure
like any other data structure example
linked list arrays Etc
so graph is a little different from the
other types of data structures such as
linked lists and Aries they are linear
data structures whereas graph is a
non-linear data structure that consists
of finite sets of vertices and a bunch
of edges connecting with them
so what are these vertices and edges so
let us understand that a graph is
usually represented by a set of vertices
and edges so a vertice is the node
present in a graph imagine that you are
a group of five friends so each one of
you is considered as a vertex and the
network connecting you guys is known as
an edge
so the overall graph of you people can
be considered as G and it is represented
by vertices and edges set where vertices
is U and the network connecting you guys
is called as an edge
so here you can see it clearly each one
of the friend is called as a vertex and
the network connecting them is called as
an edge and the entire graph is
represented using a set of vertices and
edges now moving ahead we will
understand the craft terminologies
now at first we have the adjacency
vertices and adjacency edges so what are
adjacent vertices
if there is an edge between two vertices
that is one vertex or one node is
connected to another node directly using
just one single edge then those vertices
are called as adjacent vertices now what
are adjacent edges if there is one
common vertex between two edges then
those two edges are called as adjacent
edges let's imagine this way let us
imagine that we have three vertexes and
these three vertexes are connected using
two edges so here we have one vertex
which is common between these two edges
so such type of edges are called as
adjacent edges
next we have the degree in an undirected
graph number of vertices adjacent to the
vertex is called as a degree
next is the path the path is considered
as a sequence of distinct vertices such
that two consecutive vertices are
adjacent to each other
up next we have the cycle a path that
has only one repeated vertices are
called as first and last vertices
followed by that we have the work the
term work is self-explanatory a work is
the sequence of vertices and edges in
the graph which is used to Traverse
through one vertex to another vertex
now we have entered the next segment of
this particular tutorial where we will
be discussing the different types of
graphs available
so at first we have the finite graph so
what exactly is a finite graph a graph
is said to be finite when the number of
vertices and the number of edges are in
a finite number or in a countable number
now the next type of graph is the
infinite graph so what exactly is the
infinite graph so the infinite graph is
a typical opposite of the finite graph
so this particular graph will not have
countable number of edges and countable
number of vertices
the image here is an example for a
typical infinite graph
now followed by the infinite graph we
have the trivial graph so what is a
trivial graph a graph is said to be
trivial if there is only one single
vertex without any edges
so this particular type of graph will
only have vertex that is only one single
vertex not more than one and there will
be no Edge if you have just one vertex
then there is no possibility of having
an edge unless if you have one single
Loop type of edge which is connecting to
itself but in a trivial graph we don't
even have that we just have one single
vertex
so followed by trivial graph we have a
simple graph so what exactly is a sample
graph
a graph is said to be simple if there is
only one and one Edge between each
vertex
so this particular example can be
considered as a simple graph so here
each and every set of vertices have one
single edge between them
now followed by the simple graph we have
the multigraph
so if there are multiple edges between
the pair of vertices then this
particular type of graph is known as a
multi-graph so here you can see that we
have two vertices A and B and we have
two edges connecting then not one but
two but in a simple graph we were
supposed to have just one Edge
connecting the vertices so this is the
difference between simple graph and a
multi graph
so followed by multigraph we have a null
graph so what is a null graph a graph is
said to be null if there are only
vertices and no edges between them so
remember the trivial graph right we just
had one single vertex but no edges but
here we do have multiple vertices but
now we are disconnecting them so this
type of a graph is considered as null
graph so followed by null graph we have
the complete graph
so what is a complete graph a graph is
called as a complete graph where each
vertex must be connected with the other
vertices using the edges so the meaning
of this particular type of graph is all
the edges are connected to all the other
edges using at least one single edge so
here you can see a is connected to b d
and c all together with at least one
Edge and similarly all other vertices
are connected to each other with at
least one single edge
now followed by the complete graph we
have the pseudo graph so what is a
pseudograph a pseudograph is a graph
where at least one vertex will have
self-looping type of edge so remember
the self Loop or self Edge we have
discussed in the trivial graph type so
this particular type of NH where it
connects to itself is called as a loop
or kind of self-connecting edge so any
graph that has this kind of a edge is
called as a pseudograph
so followed by the pseudograph we have
the directed graph so what is a
directory graph any graph is called as a
director graph where each Edge has a
direction associated with it so so far
we have just discussed the edges which
are connecting to one or the other
vertex but there was no Direction but
here you can see that this particular
Edge has a direction that is from B to a
not from A to B it is from B to a this
type of edges which are directing the
traversal of the graph are known as the
directed graphs
now followed by the directed graphs we
have the regular graph so a graph is a
regular graph where each vertex of the
graph has the same degree now here you
can see all the vertices have the same
amount of degree that is the connection
between all the other vertices so the
degree of as3 so the degree of B is also
3 and the degree of DSC and similarly
the degree of C is also 3.
so what I mean to say is all of these
vertices have the same degree that as 3.
now we have the weighted graph so what
is a weighted graph a weighted graph is
where each Edge holds some weight that
denotes the traversal cost through those
edges now here you can see that all the
edges have a different weight The Edge
from A to B has the weight 5 and the H
from a to c has the weight 9. and the H
from C to B has 2 and the h a to d as 8
and finally C to T as 7. so all these
values are the weight or the cost to
Traverse from a to another vertex row so
from A to B we have the cost 5 and a to
c we have the COS 9 and similarly C to D
we have 7 and so on
now followed by the weighted graph we
have the connected graph so what exactly
is a connected graph a graph is said to
be connected where each pair in the
graph is connected
followed by connected graph we have the
disconnected graph so it is a typical
opposite of the connected graph a graph
is said to be disconnected where each
pair in the graph is not connected to
each other
now next we have the cyclic graph so a
graph is set to be cyclic if it contains
at least one cycle in a graph that is
one complete traversal connection so a
can be traversed again from traveling a
to c c to d d to B and B to a again so
this type of a graph is called as a
cyclic graph
now next we have the acyclic graph so it
is the typical opposite of the
cyclograph so here it cannot travels to
a Again by traversing from a to c c to D
and there is no connection between D to
B so the complete cycle is not available
here this type of graphs are called as
acyclic graphs
so moving ahead we have the graph
representation
so generally there are two different
ways to represent the graph data
structure
they are using adjacency Matrix and
adjacency list
so what is adjacency Matrix
so adjacency Matrix is a sequential
representation adjacency Matrix is used
to represent which nodes are connected
to which node if there is an edge
between two vertices then the value of
the corresponding element of the graph
is one otherwise zero if there is any
weighted graph besides then zeros and
bonds we can store the weight of the H
as that particular number so suppose
that there is a connection between a and
b and it is represented as a weight of 5
then there is a connection so we will
use the connection as true but we will
not represent it as one instead we will
use the bit that is 5 to represent it as
5 not as one if there is no weight then
we will represent it as 1 and if there
is no connection then we will represent
it as 0.
now undirected graph representation
so here you can see how we have
represented a graph so there is no
connection between a to a that is there
is no Loop so the value will be zero if
there was a loop and if it was
represented width of it then we could
have written a weight here since we do
not have weight then the no connection
is represented as 0 and a connection is
represented as one we have a connection
from A to B so we have represented it as
1 and similarly to a to c so and so on
now directed graph representation so the
simple difference between the directed
and undirected graph representation is
we did not have a direction in the
previous segment but here we do have
directions so B is connected to a but a
is not connected to B so we will write
it as 0 because the control is
traversing from B to a but not from A to
B so we need to take care of the
traversal of control so we are
representing as 0 and you can see from D
to B we have one connection and the
traversal is in the direction of D 2B so
we will have one there so here we have D
and B so we have one so in that way we
represent the directed graphs
next undirected weight troughs
so this was what we discussed before
instead of zeros and ones we will
represent the weight here so we do not
have a connection between a to a so that
is 0 as usual but we do have a
connection from A to B so we have
represented it with a number that
happens to be the weight of the edge and
remember we do not have the direction
here this is undirected weighted graph
now if it were the directed weighted
graph then we could have seen the
direction and represented the number
with the weight now after this let us
look into the adjacency list
so what is adjacency list adjacency list
is a linked representation
in this representation we maintain the
list of its neighbors for each vertex in
the graph every vertex of the graph
contains the list of adjacency vertices
array of vertices which have vertices
indexed by each vertex number for every
vertex the array element points to the
linked list of the neighbors of the
vertex so this might be a little
complicated to understand so let us
understand this using an example
so directed graph representation
implemented using linked list
so this is the directed graph we are
using
so you can see that a is not connected
to anything so we have ended the address
of next location as X but B is connected
to a and C is connected to a similarly D
is also connected to E
so that is how we represent the
directed graphs using linked lists
next we have directed graph
representation using array
so a is not connected to anything so we
have represented as 0 and V is connected
to B as well as a so we have 1 there and
C is connected to B
so C is also connected to a so we have 2
there D is connected to a c and b so we
have 3 there
now we have the graph trap version
so graph traversal refers to the process
of examining each Edge and vertex in a
graph
revising can be performed in two ways
the first one is breadth first search or
BFS algorithm BFS starts traversing the
graph from root node and expose all the
neighboring nodes then it selects the
nearest node and explores all the new
nodes Q data structure can be used in
BFS algorithm
so the following image depicts the apfs
algorithm working
it chooses the nearest node first then
it traverses to all the other nodes
so followed by BFS algorithm we have the
DFS algorithm that is the depth first
search algorithm DFS starts traversing a
graph from the initial node of the graph
and then it goes deeper and deeper until
it finds the node has no child there the
backtrack from the dead end towards the
recently explored nodes stack is used
for BFS algorithms so this particular
gif image can be considered as the
graphed reversal which is performed
using DFS algorithms so if you don't
know much about DFS and BFS algorithms
don't worry about that those particular
tutorial videos are added in the
description box below you can go through
it and understand BFS and DFS algorithms
in a much better way now we will go
through some of the applications of
graphs
so some of the major applications of
graphs are used in the website Google
Maps and social media websites like
Facebook and some security systems
and also software programming
the crystals algorithm is used to find
the minimum spanning tree for a given
graph but what exactly is a minimum
spanning tree or MST well a minimum
spanning tree is a subset of graph G
having the same number of vertices as of
graph G and age is equivalent to number
of vertices -1 along with these
properties it also has a minimum cost
for the summation of all age weights
included in a minimum swanning tray
if you want to learn more about spanning
trades then please consider watching our
video which you can find in the I button
section right away
now coming back to the crystals
algorithm the crystals algorithm sorts
all ages in increasing order of their
age weights and keeps adding notes to
the tree only if the given age does not
form a cycle also it picks the age with
minimum cost at first and the age with
maximum cost at last hence we can say
that the couscous algorithm makes a
locally optimal Choice intending to find
global optimal solution that is why it
is also considered as greedy algorithm
the data structure that we are going to
use for implementing this cuscals
algorithm is Union fine
but now you must be thinking what
exactly is this Union fine data
structure and how it works well Union
fine is a data structure that keeps
tracks of element that are split into
one or more than one disjoint sets where
a disjoint set its collection of two
distinct groups or clusters that do not
have single common element the union
fine features two important operations
named as find and Union
the operation find Returns the set or
group to which provided element belongs
basically it constructs a bijection
between the object provided and its set
whereas the Union function joins two
distinct disjoint sets to create a
single subset let's understand how this
data structure works with the help of
real life example
let's say we have some singing magnets
placed on table with a higher magnetic
Affinity towards each other all these
syncing magnets present on the table are
color coded with sky blue color now due
to the high magnetic attraction the
magnets a to e will form a strong
magnetic field which will cause the
bonding or connection of all these
magnets as a result all these magnets
will be grouped together we will now
color code this set with red color along
with that we'll also call this set as
red
after that the magnet f2i are also
closer to each other thus they will also
form a connection we'll call this set as
green finally this last set of magnets
will also formulate a connection with
each element inside a group we will call
this group as set purple
all these distinct magnets got
distributed into three different
disjoint sets but as the magnetic
attraction between these groups
increases significantly hence all these
clusters of magnets will end up
connecting with each other this scenario
can be related to the Union function
Union function merges different sets
into a single subset where the find
operation helps in extracting the group
of element to which the particular
element belongs similarly in this
scenario a particular magnet can be
traced back to its group with the help
of color code that we have maintained
alongside the magnets
the use of Union find in Crystal's
algorithm can be related to this example
while implementing cruscal's algorithm
we are going to maintain three distinct
disjoint sets the first set will store
age weight values for all ages in a
graph whereas the second set will store
tree hierarchy for a different notes the
last set will store the ranks for all
nodes included in an MSD by using the
union fine structure and its operation
we can justify the entry of each Edge
into the spanning tree which we will
explain in the implementation of this
algorithm but let's understand the
functioning of this algorithm primarily
the crystals algorithm begins with
sorting all edges into increasing order
of their age weights this sorting is
done to include edges with the least age
weight primarily into the tree structure
after that we will pick the first
smallest Edge and we'll check if it
generate any cycle in the tree structure
or not if it does not form any cycle
then we will include that edge into our
spanning tree or otherwise we will
discard it we will keep repeating this
process until mod of V minus 1 edges are
included into our MSD where V is number
of vertices now moving ahead let's
discuss how we can create a minimum
spanning tree using couscous algorithm
this given graph g v e contains 12 edges
and 6 vertices and we are supposed to
find out G Dash such that the number of
vertices is equal to 6 and the number of
edges is equal to V minus 1 that is 6
minus 1 which is equal to 5. the one
more condition that the formulated
structure must abide by is that the
summation of all included Edge weights
must be the minimum possibility for the
spanning tree going forward we'll
discuss how we are going to create MST
for this graph using couscous algorithm
the first step that we need to perform
is removing all the loops or parallel
edges from our graph hence primarily
we'll remove these two present Loops The
Next Step that we are going to perform
is arranging all the edges in increasing
order of their weights
the reason behind maintaining the sorted
list is to make sure that the first Edge
for insertion is of a minimum cost here
I have maintained the sorted list for
all the edges that are part of our graph
so according to this sorted list the
first age that we are going to insert in
our MST is h e f as it has minimum
weight cost that is 2. the next stage
that we have in our sorted list is hfd
it also has an edge weight equal to 2
hence we'll include it in our spanning
trick
the third Edge in our sorted list is HBC
with weight 3. the inclusion of this
Edge does not formulate any Circle in
artery structure hence We'll add it to
our MSD the next stage is
hcf having the age weight 3 so we'll
include it in our MSD structure
the fifth age that we are going to pick
is hcd having weight 4 but the inclusion
of this age inside a spanning tree will
create a loop and the structure that
contains a loop can never be considered
as tree hence we have to exclude this
Edge
the next age is age BF and the inclusion
of this age will also generate a cycle
in our spanning tree structure
so we will exclude this age as well
the next age
is hbd
this age has weight value 6. the
inclusion of this age can also create a
loop in our structure so even though
this Edge has higher weight value than
previous ages but it does not formulate
any cycle in our MSD so we'll include it
in our tree structure by doing that we
have generated V minus 1 edges for our
spanning tree thus we want iterate
further in our sorted list this
generated MSD has minimum possible cost
for our graph gve which is 17. I hope
that you guys have understood the MST
implementation process using Crystal's
algorithm because in the next slide I
have a problem for all of you guys to
assess your understanding of cuscal's
algorithm
the craft shown on your screen contains
10 vertices and 18 edges and for this
graph you are supposed to generate a
minimum spanning tree such that it
contains 10 vertices 9 edges and minimum
construction cost in order to do that
you can take out your pen and paper to
draw the spanning tree structures based
on the step that we have discussed till
the time I am aware that this graph is
quite strangely structured however if
you can solve this problem you will
undoubtedly be able to solve other
difficult problems out there and of
course if you are confused about any
step then you can reiterate through the
session but here I am going to give you
guys a little moment to figure out your
answers
well now that you guys must be ready
with your solution so let's check if it
is true the highlighted part of this
graph is possible structure for spanning
tree with minimal cost
by removing all the edges the MST will
look something like this I hope you guys
have got the right answer on that note
let's dive further and discuss the
implementation strategy for cuscal's
algorithm
while implementing The crucial algorithm
primarily will generate a c structure
for keeping track of the source and
destination node along with its weight
after that we'll sort all that edges of
a graph in increasing order of the age
weights
moving ahead we'll create three distinct
sets to maintain nodes of a graph their
hierarchy entry and corresponding ranks
for every node for each insertion of an
age in MST we'll update the rank and
parent of each node
if the two nodes have the same parent
node then we will not insert the edge
joining them as it will generate the
cycle in tree structure let's understand
all these steps with the help of an
example
this is the graph structure for which
we'll try to generate a minimum spanning
tree using C programming language
as discussed earlier primarily we'll
create a sorted list of all ages in
increasing order of the age weights the
list will contain the source node
destination node and corresponding age
weight for that particular age along
with that we are going to maintain
disjoint sets to carry out Union
operation those disjoint sets are parent
and rank and they will include rank
value and parent value for every node in
our graph initially all the nodes are in
their own different sets hence we'll set
their parent values to -1 also the ranks
for these nodes will be initialized to 0
at the beginning because we haven't
included them in our minimum spanning
tree having said that let's include the
nodes of our graph in our MSD in
upcoming slides we'll Traverse through
our list of Ages to include them in our
minimum spanning tree now the first is
that we are going to check is HDC which
have minimum age cost that is 1. in
order to insert this Edge in our MST
we'll need to find the absolute parent
of node D and C as well so let's check
out the parent set to determine the
absolute parent value of node DNC the
parent value of node D is -1 and parent
value of node C is also minus 1.
both of them are having same ranks which
means either we can make no D point to c
or node C point to D here I'll assume
that node D points to node C so if node
D is pointing to node C then the parent
of node D will become node C
and as C becomes the parent of node D
the rank of node c will change
remember whenever two disjoint tree
structures are joined together then the
rank of 1 being 0.82 will increase by 1.
hence the rank of node c will become 1
now
once the disjoint sets are updated the
union operation will generate the link
between node d and c
now we'll process the second Edge in our
list that is H CB having weight 2.
primarily we'll check the parent values
of both these nodes node B and node C
have parent values minus 1 and -1
which indicates that these nodes are
absolute parent of their own sets since
they have different absolute parents we
can join both of them
however the rank of node C is higher
than node B thus the connection should
point from node B to node C
as node B is pointing towards node C
thus node c will become the parent of
node b as well
hence we'll update the corresponding
absolute parent values for them
next up is HBA with the weight value too
now the parent value for node a is -1
and the parent value for node B is C so
both of them have distinct parent value
which implies that we can establish a
connection between them for that purpose
we'll have to update the rank field and
as the parent of node B is node C the
rank of C will definitely increase by 1.
once the fields are updated the edge
will get included in our MSD
on that note we have generated our
minimum spanning tree but you must be
thinking about how our algorithm will
discard the other edges so to understand
that we'll Traverse further in our list
of Ages the next age is age AC and the
parent of node a is node C itself hence
we'll discard this node as well now the
final Edge in our list is h a d and
again both these nodes have the same
parent node thus we will discard this
node as well
now you must be thinking about how we
can limit iteration of the whole list if
we formulate MST using the few topmost
ages only well the answer to that is
pretty straightforward we can avoid the
complete traversal of the list by using
looping condition from a is equal to 0
to e is equal to mod of V minus 1. when
we use this condition the looping will
stop when V minus ages get included in
our MSD
now the next up is the time complexity
analysis of crystals algorithm the time
complexity of cuscal's algorithm will be
bigger of e log e plus e log V the E log
e so sorting all ages and E log V for
finding the age from maintain three sets
the average time complexity graph for
this implementation will be something
like this it will be a parabolic nature
I hope that you all have understood the
strategy for implementing preschools
algorithm so without wasting any time
further let's visit the code Editor to
develop a program in C programming
language for Crystal's algorithm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now to begin with coding implementation
the first thing that we'll do is we'll
create a storing system to represent a
weighted age for that purpose we'll use
structure in the C programming language
so let's get started with that
truck
age
and and set this structure will create
int source
destination
and wait
now what we'll do is we'll utilize this
structure to store the edges of the
graph moving ahead we'll also initialize
the structure for storing the complete
graph
so let's create one more structure
and we'll name the structure as graph
and inside this graph structure we'll
create
node
will also create variable e to represent
number of edges in our graph
we will also call the reference of
structure H to this graph by doing this
we'll be able to include all the edges
into our graph structure as well so
let's create that reference
age
star
h
now we have successfully created the
structure for graph
now moving forward what we'll do is
we'll assign dynamic memory to the
reference of graph structure for that
what we'll do is we'll write code struct
graph
star
generate
graph
and inside this function will pass end
node
and
the number of edges that is e variable
now we'll write body for this function
and inside body first thing what we'll
do is we'll create
the space
that is dynamic memory space for this
graph structure
equal to struct
graph
star
malloc
sides off
struct
graph
next
dot node
will be equal to node
and
graph
DOT number of
H is
will be equal to
e itself
next what we'll do is
will unlock it a memory to each Edge
okay I'll add underscore here
for that what we'll do is we'll use
struct
H star
malloc
sides of
truth
h
and finally we'll return
the graph
now we have successfully allocated
memory space to our graph and individual
edges as well so moving forward what
we'll do is we'll initialize one more
structure to store the parent array and
rank array basically these are the
disjoint sets whose usage will allow us
to generate a spanning tree using Union
find algorithm so let's get started with
that we'll create another structure and
we'll name the structure as tree
underscore maintainance
underscore set
and and set this structure will create
parent array
and
rank array
now we have created the tree maintenance
set structure so let's generate an Union
find algorithm for maintaining MST
structure in order to do that let's
create a function name findis joint set
first
so this find this joint set function
will be of int data type
find
underscore
disjoint
set
and inside this will pass
dropped
tree underscore
dignance
underscore set
and its object
subsets
and
a variable and I
insert this function we'll use its case
to find root and make it as a parent of
argument I also if it is minus 1 then
we'll need to update it for that we'll
keep recurring through this a block by
calling the function find this joint set
and set a block so let's do that if
subsets
I
dot parent
is not equal to
I
then what we'll do is
we'll get inside this F log and will
execute
subsets
I
dot parent
is equal to
find
underscore
disjoint set
and will again pass same argument
subsets
comma
I
dot parent
and finally
will get out of this F block
and will return
subsets
I
dot parent
foreign
operation let's name this function as
void
Union
underscore
this joint
set
and insert this will pass
dropped
tree underscore
maintenance
underscore set
and its object
subsets
and we'll pass
argument X and argument
y
now inside this function we'll create
two variables named X root and by root
and the X root variable will store the
return data from find this joint set
when the X has been passed to the
function and similarly the Y root will
store the return value for fine disjoint
set given y as an argument so let's
write command for that
and
X root
will be equal to find
this joint set
and objects will be subsets
comma X
similarly in y root
will be equal to find
this trend set
and object subsets
and
variable y
now in order to build connection between
these nodes as discussed previously the
node with lowest rank value should
always be pointing to the node with
highest rank value and vice versa so
we'll have to use this if Block in order
to put this condition in the connection
building block of our program so we'll
write condition for that here now if
subsets
exude
dot rank
it's greater less than
subsets
y root
dot rank
then what we'll do is
will set
subsets
X root
dot parent
to Y root
that means
well okay
so what we are doing here is we are
checking the rank value of x root if the
rank value of x root is smaller than y
root then what we'll do is we'll simply
set the wire root as parent of X root I
hope you guys are clear with this now
moving forward we'll write LC part of
this condition
else if
subset
X root
dot rank
sorry
I'll have to add s here
and
F subsets X root dot rank is greater
than subsets
y root
Dot
rank
then what we'll do is
we will
set subsets
y root
dot parent
it's equal to X root
or the whites
a both above mentioned condition fail
then what we'll do is we'll add one more
condition we'll set subset
y root
dot parent
to
X root
and then we
set subset
X root
Dot
rank
to incrementation
there is one mistake over here
subsets okay
so now we have implemented the union
find algorithm for this critical
implementation next we'll create a
function to sort the list of edges in
our graph according to increasing order
of their age weights so let's create new
function for that we'll name this
function as and my comparator
and inside it will pass
const
ant star
a
and const
ant void
star
p
and we'll create function body but
before we get started with coding
implementation of this my comparator
function I want to talk about arguments
of this function
so basically A and B are constant
quantifiers the significance of this
quantifier is to tell the user that you
cannot modify this pointer and the
location it is pointing to throughout
the program
so let's
get started with the coding part of this
my comparator function what we'll do is
will create
extract
age
star
A1
is equal to
struct
age
star
a
semicolon and similarly
construct
h
star
B1
will be equal to
truth
each star
B
next we'll return the output
a 1
foreign
it's greater than
B1
Dot weight
so basically what this statement will do
is if the weight value of A1 is greater
than B1 then it will return A1 as output
and if the weight value of B1 is greater
than a 1 then it will return B1
I hope you guys are clear with this my
comparator function so moving forward
will finally create a crystal MSD
function
return type of this function will be
void
and will name this as criscal MST
and inside it will pass argument
struct graph
and will create function body
now the first thing that we'll do here
is we'll assess the value of number of
nodes in a graph and after that we'll
generate a new reference of structure
age for storing our MSD so the first
thing will
keep
the node
to
graph
Dot
node
and
extract
age
result
node
along with it we'll also initialize
variable e and variable I equal to 0 so
end e
is equal to 0
and end
I
is equal to zero we need to break the
indentation here
and here as well
and semicolon so basically these
variables will store index values for
result and index variable for the sorted
list simultaneously now moving forward
we'll sort all the edges of a graph if
we are not allowed to change the given
graph then we can create a copy of the
given graph the function name Q sort
allows us to do that so let's create
that Q sort function here
Q sort
graph
h
comma
graph
a
comma size of
graph
h
so this Q sort is nothing but C standard
Library function that implements a
polymorphic sorting algorithm for arrays
of arbitrary objects according to a user
provided comparison function and that
comparison function is nothing but this
my comparison function
and
I guess you guys must be clear with this
Q short term
so let's add
comma here and will give call
to a
my comparator function
now moving forward we'll break the
indentation
and
will call
the object of tree maintenance set
underscore
maintenance
[Music]
set
subsets
equal to
3 underscore
maintenance
underscore
set
star
malloc
node
star
size off
struct
Ure tree underscore
maintenance
underscore set
foreign here
so next we'll create subsets equal to
number of nodes and after that we'll
make sure that all the elements have the
rank value equal to zero and to do that
we'll initialize new for Loop
so let's create for Loop here
will begin it from V is equal to zero to
V
is less than node
and we'll set this way to incrementation
after that we'll make body for this for
Loop and inside it we'll set
subsets V
dot parent
is equal to
V
and subsets
Dot rank
is equal to
zero
now moving further
will Traverse through all the edges in
the graph but we want to limit our
traversal to the number of vertices -1
and to achieve that we'll create while
loop here
file
e
is less than node
Capital node
then
node minus 1
and and
I
it's
smaller than
graph
e
foreign
create struct
age
next underscore h
equal to
graph
Dot
h
I plus plus
and here
will create
X and Y nodes
so
let's do that int X
will be equal to
find underscore
disjoint set
and will pass subsets
comma
next h
dot source
and for y
will pass
find underscore destroyed sets
subsets
comma
next underscore h
dot destination
now if including the H between X and Y
does not create the cycle in our graph
only then we can include that edge in
our MSD for that what we can do is we'll
set if x
it's not equal to y
then
we'll set result
e plus plus
equal to
next
underscore Edge
and we'll find unions
this joint set
for subset
and will pass X and Y as well
with this we have successfully created
our Crystal semester function
now what we'll do is we'll also print
the structure of our minimum spanning
tree for that we'll need to create
pattern using printf function so let's
do that
the first statement that will print on
screen is edges
created
in MST
are ads below
and we'll add backslash n so that our
output gets to the next line
we'll add semicolon and
do that
will add end
minimum
cost
variable
and will initialize it to zero
so
okay
what we'll do is
we'll create for Loop here and we'll
initialize it with iterator 11 beginning
from 0
till
I
less than equal to E
and will
I take this I element
and what we'll do is we'll create
pattern for printing the edges the
pattern will go like modulus d
Dash Dash
modulus d
equal to equal to
slash NS
and
the parameters that will get printed
will be result
I
dot source
comma
result
I
Dot
destination
and
result
I
Dot
weight
okay
so we haven't added comma here
now this error will get result
now after this what we'll do is
will increment this minimum cost
variable by adding the values of edges
to it so we'll take this minimum cost
variable
and
will add
result
I
dot weight to it
now we'll get outside this for Loop
and
will print f one more statement
cost
for creating
MST as
modulus d
and
will print minimum cost
okay we have now successfully
implemented triscal's algorithm function
and we have created code for printing it
on Console as well so now moving forward
will work on our driver method
and for that let's
get into its function body
here first we'll Define the number of
nodes that we are going to use for our
graph
those number of nodes are 4
the graph structure that we are going to
pass to this crystals algorithm program
is the same that we have discussed
implementation strategy for it had four
edges and it also had six
H is as well
so
we'll add six edges here
now what we'll do is we'll set struct
graph
star
equal to
generate
crop
and will pass node
comma
e
and we'll add semicolon
now next we'll create graph structure by
implementing the edges
so the for
first stage
will call graph
Dot
h
dot source
will be equal to zero
that means
the first age will begin from 0 and it
will
end at
destination
load and that will be
one
and the weight
for this
age will be
equal to
now we'll copy this pattern
and
will paste it below
okay
and now
the age
will be 1
and for this
H1 The Source will be 0 and destination
will be 2 and the weight value will be
4.
now
let's copy this again
and paste it
and we'll set
age number to two
will change source
and destination now Source will remain
same and destination will be changed
will make it 3
and the weight value will also remain
the same that means
H between 0 to 2 and H between 0 to 3
have same age weight
now
for next Ctrl V
we'll remove this indentation and now
we'll change the node number the age
number
here
The Source will be 1
and destination will be
and the age weight value
will be 3.
after this we'll add new
h
the H number will be 4 now
The Source will be
two
and destination will be
three
and age weight would be one
and the last page
will be
H5
and
The Source will be
1 here
and destination will be 2
the age weight will be 2.
now after this what we'll do is we'll
give call to our physical MSD function
in order to generate minimum spanning
tree and will pass this graph structure
to it
and we'll add return 0 statement
with this we have successfully completed
a programming implementation for
cuscal's algorithm
so let's run it and check if a code is
working fine or not
okay so we are getting three problems
here
the first one
it's expected token oh
and mode will be equal to
because
and this node should also be Capital
here
okay
so what next error is there
yeah
so now a code is bug free
oh
but some exception is happening here
will jump this exception we'll try to
jump it
okay but we are not having any errors
into our system so
I think that's the compatibility issue
with our vs code so let's copy this code
and paste it into
the virtual coding environment and we'll
check it if this code is working fine or
not
so we'll copy the code
and we'll go back to the Google Chrome
will go to the online compiler tool
and here
will paste our code
will run it
okay so here we are getting our output
so there will be only three edges that
will get formed in our minimum spanning
tree and the cost for all those HS will
be 5.
I hope this coding implementation is
clear to all of you out there
if you are concerned about this code
then don't be as we can send it over to
you if you drop your email IDs in the
comment section below so drop your email
IDs in the comment section below in
order to receive this code backtracking
is an algorithmic method of alternately
solving a problem
who explain the issues it employs a
recursive approach backtracking is
required to find every possible
combination to solve an optimization
problem
backtracking is used in solving various
problems like end Queens night store the
rat in the Maze problems and so on
now to get better understanding of
backtracking let's have a brief look at
and queens problem
let's say we have four by four Matrix we
have to place Four Queens in that every
row and column has exactly one Queen and
none of them falls under the same
diagonal we will start with the leftmost
column then we will check our base
condition that if we have placed all the
queens or not
now we will try every Row in this column
if we found a location where the queen
can be safely placed then we will mark
it as a part of an answer
and then we will recursively check if
placing Queen here will lead us to the
solution or not
if yes then we will return true
otherwise if false then we will
backtrack and try other rows and repeat
these steps if all rows have been tried
and nothing worked then we will return
false to trigger backtracking
now let's implement this end Queens
problem in the code reader
we will Define a vector
inside a vector
it will be an interactor
result
now we will write a utility function to
check if the queen can be placed on
board
so
it will be a Boolean function
bull is safe
as argument we will place a vector
inside a vector
and
board
comma
and row
comma and
column
will Define
and I comma J
and
and will be equals to board size
now we will check if this row on the
left side
so
for Loop
I is equals to 0
I less than column
I plus plus
f
old
at row
I
then we will return
now we will check upper diagonal on left
side
so for
I is equals to rho
comma J
is equals to column
J greater than equals to 0
and
I greater than equals to zero
I minus minus comma
J
minus minus
if
board
I
comma J
then return
now we will check lower diagonal on left
side
so for
I equals to rho
comma J is equals to column
I
I less than n
and
J greater than equals to zero
I plus plus comma J minus minus
now if
old
at I
and J
will return
else we will return
basically what we have done in this
function is we have checked that row and
the right diagonal and the left diagonal
so that no Queen can overlap
now next we will write a recursive
utility function to solve end Queens
problem
so pull
all
and Q
its argument will be vector
inside a vector
enter
Ampersand board
comma and
column
now we will first check our base case if
all queens are placed
so end
n is equals to
board size
if
for them
is equals to n
then we will Define a vector
and
p
so 4
and I is equals to zero
I less than n
and I plus plus
another Nester for Loop
and J is equals to zero
J less than n
J plus plus
if
board
at I
and J
is equals to 1.
then
V Dot push
back
J plus one
now
we will print result
Dot pushback
and we will return
true
now we will consider this column and try
placing this queen in all rows one by
one
so
Boolean
does
is equals to false
now for Loop
and I is equals to zero
I less than n
I plus plus
now we will check if Queens can be
placed on board I can call them call
so if
is safe
board
my eye
on my call
if it's safe then we will
change this coin at that position so
board
I
call
is equals to 1.
now we will make result true if any
placement is possible
so
press
is equals to
solve
and Cube
at board
comma
call
plus one
or res
now if placing Queen in board I call
doesn't lead to a solution then we will
remove the queen from the board I column
and backtrack
some board
now if Queen cannot be placed in any row
in this column then we will return false
so
return
Plus
now this function solves the end Queen
problem using backtracking it is
basically using solve and Q to solve the
problem
it returns false if Queen cannot be
placed otherwise returns true and print
placement of Queens in the form of once
now there may be possibility that there
are more than one solution
then this function will print one of the
feasible solution
vector
write a vector
and queen
and
n
result
Dot
clear
now we will call vector
inside a vector
board
n comma
vector
and
bracket n comma zero
now if
solve
NQ
at board
comma zero
is false
then we will return
empty set
otherwise
we will sort
begin
comma
result
Dot
and
and we will return
result
now we will write the main block
so and
n is equals to 4
so 4
Factor
inside vector
hint
V will be equals to n Queens
at n
so we will write for Loop
Auto
a r
V
we will call C out
then for Loop
Auto
ATR
AR
C out
r
and C out
and then we will return 0.
now let's run this code
as you can see we are getting two
answers now this end Queen can be solved
with both of these answers
now let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up backtracking is simple to
implement and has fewer lines of code
most backtracking codes are composed of
few lines of recursion function code
next
since we use recursion the function
information is stored on the stack which
has high space complexity
next when the branching factor is
significant it is very time consuming in
many cases
finally many problems such as night
store and queens rat in the Maze subsets
and problem and so on can be solved
using backtracking choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1000
plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
we will have a look at an application of
the spanning tree to understand it
better
meet Patrick Patrick works is ahead of
the network administration department in
an I.T solution company named as gray
Solutions being the head of network
administration department Patrick is
responsible for managing his team to
keep the organization's computer network
up to date and operate it as intended
Network administration department
coordinates and connects multiple
systems in the company to a single
network using multiple routers
this network is called as local area
network or Lan which is created for the
sole use of an I.T company
but in the last few days something went
wrong in the network management system
which came to Patrick's notice
he observed that the network loop is
formed in a routing system a network
loop occurs when multiple routes carry
information from the same source to
various Computing devices
and due to this formation of a network
loop the network connectivity started
slowing down initially after a few hours
the network connectivity completely went
down and all the operations of the
company stopped abruptly
now Patrick and his team needed to do
something in order to resolve this
problem permanently
so Patrick started brainstorming to find
out an optimal solution to fix this
problem
one of Patrick's teammate was good at
data structures and he came forward with
an idea to implement a spanning tree
data structure for managing the routing
connections he suggested replacing the
old nive routing strategy with a minimal
spanning tree routing
after listening to this idea the whole
network Administration team started
working on implementing a spanning tree
while doing that they treated the
network connection as a graph the
routers and end devices like computers
fax machines were treated as the nodes
of the graph where the connecting wires
carrying Network signals were treated as
the edges of a graph
but before understanding how Patrick's
team was able to solve this problem
using a minimum spanning tree let's
first understand the basics of this data
structure
this will allow us to get a clearer
insight into how spanning tree solves
Network routing problems so let's start
with graph and its different types
basically a graph is a structure made of
nodes and edges connecting them and
there are three types of these graphs
based on the types of edges
the first is the undirected graph the
second is the directed graph and the
last is the connected graph
let's understand these types completely
in the upcoming slides
the first type of graph that we are
going to discuss is the undirected graph
it is termed as a graph in which all the
edges does not point to any specific
Direction in simpler words all the edges
of this graph will be bi-directional
as you can see in this particular graph
you can move from any node to any other
node and retrieve back as well
in this particular type of graph you can
reach any vertex from any other vertex
in a graph for example you can go to
node b or d from node a and arrive back
at a from either vertex P or D
now moving ahead we will understand what
a spanning tree is and how we can create
it
mathematically the spanning tree for any
graph G having vertices V and edges e
can be represented using superscript
notation G Dash having vertices V Dash
and edges e Dash
suppose we intend to create a spanning
tree for graph G then R spanning Tree G
Dash must follow few constraints
the first constraint suggests that the
number of vertices for created spanning
tree must be equal to the number of
vertices of a given graph G
further the edges of G Dash should also
be similar to the number of vertices in
graph G minus 1. to understand this
mathematical formulation clearly let's
have a look at an example
now for this given graph G we have to
formulate all possible spanning trees
remember a single connected graph can
have multiple spanning trees until we
fulfill the constraints mentioned
earlier
so for this particular graph G we have
five vertices and five edges
additionally each Edge has been assigned
with some cost or weight
let's say this weight represents the
distance between the connected two nodes
to create the spanning tree g Dash we
need to ensure that g Dash contains five
vertices and five minus 1 that is four
edges
hence for this graph we can create a
spanning tree like this
you can observe that we have eliminated
one node in the spanning tree to remove
the loop or cycle in a graph
for this spanning tree one we have a
cost or value equal to 10 and this cost
is nothing but the summation of all Edge
weights
now that we have created the first
spanning tree for our graph G I would
like to ask all of you to give this a
try
for that I am going to provide you with
a short moment to generate all possible
spanning trees for the structure that we
are discussing right now
you can also pause this video if you
need more time in order to do that
so now let's have a look at all possible
spanning trees at a glance we have seen
that the value for the first spanning
tree was 10.
and for this new spanning tree too it is
13. in this spanning tree The Edge
between vertices B and C is removed
the next spanning tree looks something
like this with cost 14.
further We have spanning tree number
four with a value 12.
and finally we have the last possible
spanning tree Phi with a value 11.
out of all these spanning trees the
value or cost for spanning tree number
one is the least which is 10. thus this
spanning tree will be called as minimum
spanning tree
I hope you're clear with the creation of
spanning trees but how can we judge the
number of all the possible spanning
trees
well for that you need to check the
structure of your graph if the graph you
have been given with is cyclic then the
number of possible spanning trees will
be equal to the number of vertices
the cyclic graph is a graph in which you
will have the same number of vertices
and edges with a cyclic structure
if the given graph is a complete graph
then the number of possible spanning
trees will be equal to V raised to V
minus 2. where V is the number of
vertices in a given graph you can say
that the given graph is a complete graph
if each pair of vertices is connected by
The Unique Edge
for this particular graph the number of
possible spanning trees will be equal to
the number of vertices that is 4 to the
power of 4 minus 2 which is further
equivalent to the square of 4. hence the
number of possible spanning trees for
this structure will be 16.
moving forward let's understand some
important properties of spanning tree
we have already gone through some
crucial properties while creating
spanning trees in the previous section
so primarily we will list all of them
here the first property of a spanning
tree conveys that a connected graph can
have more than one spanning tree
the next property states that the number
of vertices and spanning trees must be
equal to the number of vertices in the
given graph whereas the number of edges
is equivalent to the mod of V minus 1.
the third property of a spanning tree
says that the spanning tree must not
contain any cycle if the structure that
you have created as a spanning tree
includes a loop or a cycle then it's
clear that you have made a mistake
because no tree can contain a cycle
and finally the fourth property is all
about Kelly's formula if the given graph
is a complete graph then you can
calculate the number of possible
spanning trees using the formula V
raised to B minus 2.
the next property of a spanning tree
conveys that a spanning tree can never
be disconnected for example if you
create a spanning tree for this given
graph which is accurate and you erase
one Edge when you do that the structure
will no longer be a spanning tree it can
only be referred to as a disconnected
graph the next property states that if
the graph contains more than one similar
weight there is a possibility of having
more than one minimum spanning tree for
example in this particular graph there
are more than one Edge having the same
widths thus there will be two possible
minimum spanning trees with the same
cost that is 7.
this is all about the properties of
spanning trees now that you understood
what spanning tree is you would have
also understood how it proves is an
effective solution and that is exactly
how Patrick from our story solved his
Network issue in a few days Patrick and
his team changed the knife routing into
the minimum spanning tree routing now
the routing parts are managed by a
minimum spanning tree to maintain cost
Effectiveness and to avoid any looping
activity as we have already understood
and Misty removes all the loops from a
given graph and we also know that the
whole network becomes the graph for
which MSC will maintain a minimal
routing path hence the network system
will never experience a network loop
again
due to this amazing initiative Patrick
and his team were appreciated by the
whole organization
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of a spanning tree and why it
is one of the most important algorithms
in data structures
now we will look into the different
applications of spanning trees
the first application that we are going
to talk about is telecommunication
Network building
if we want to build a telecommunication
Network for the whole city and we are
putting different connection lines for
each customer then we will have to deal
with a huge cost this knife ordinary
approach is not the best solution to
build a connection line
but no worries this problem can be
resolved using the minimum spanning tree
data structure in this case each
customer will be treated as a Vertex
whereas the connection line will be
treated as an edge
the minimum spanning tree will give us
the possible output for generating the
telecommunication Network
no matter what type of algorithm you are
building using machine learning
techniques somewhere down the line you
will be using clustering techniques
quite liberally
clustering and data preparation go hand
in hand as many times you will be
working at least initially with data
sets that are largely unstructured and
unclassified
those data sets cannot be classified
using single neuron or classification
methods
so you use a clustering algorithm which
utilizes a minimum spanning tree to
create clusters or groups by mapping
distances between data points
the next application of a minimum
spanning tree is image segmentation
you must have observed that your face
gets detected with a square shape while
clicking images in selfie mode
this scenario is happening due to the
image detection algorithm developed on
the camera system
at the back end the picture gets
fragmented into tiles of similar pixels
with the help of a minimum spanning tree
the last application of the spanning
tree is its use in calculating the
finance factors
a correlation Matrix can be created by
calculating a coefficient of correlation
between any two stocks
this Matrix can be represented
topologically as a complex Network and
the minimum spanning tree can be
constructed to visualize the
relationships
so what exactly is breakfast search
algorithm so breadth first search
algorithm visits every node efficiently
and marks all the nodes which are
adjacent to that particular node the
critical nodes in the graph are in a
breadthwise manner
breakfast search starts traversing from
root node and then selects all the
unvisited adjacent nodes of the selected
node Q data structure is used to
implement BFS algorithm so here you can
see a gif which is explaining about BFS
algorithm so let us consider that we
have selected the root node as one then
it will check for all possible adjacent
nodes so it will Traverse to 2 then it
will Traverse to 3. after that it
doesn't have any adjacent nodes so the
control moves to either one of the child
nodes that is two or three so let us
consider that we go to 2 and from 2 it
will check for all the adjacent nodes
that is 4 and 5 and there are no other
adjacent nodes from two then it will go
to 4. it can also go to 5 But Here let
us consider that it goes to 4. so from 4
it does not have anything to Traverse so
it get backs to 2 then it goes to 5 and
from Phi it checks for the traversal
there is only one possibility that is 7
and no other Explorations then it goes
to 7 and there is no other possibility
for 7 as well so it comes back to 5 then
to 2 then to 1 and then it enters the
second child node that is the three from
the 3 it moves to another possibility
that is 6 and it checks for another
possibility but there is no possibility
so now the control moves from 3 to 6
from 6 it tries to visit the adjacent
nodes so 6 has only one adjacent note
that is eight and no other adjacent
nodes and now from 6 it goes to 8 and
from 8 it checks for any other adjacent
nodes but there is no other adjacent
node so it gets back to 6 then 3 then to
1 back so this is how the control
traverses when you are implementing
breadth first search algorithm
now here let us look into an example for
breadth first search algorithm as
discussed in the previous example here
the root node is selected first then it
goes to B then it goes to C and it
checks for any other adjacent node but
there is no other adjacent node other
than B and C so the control moves to B
and from B it starts traversing to all
its addition nodes first it traverses to
D then to e and it checks for any other
possibility but there is no other
possibility so the control goes backs to
B then to a and from a it traverses to C
and from C it checks for all the
adjacent nodes that is f and g so it
checks for other possibilities since
there is no other possibility it goes
through F and from f it checks for other
possibilities but there are no other
possibilities from F so the control gets
packs to C and then finally to G and in
G it checks for any adjacent nodes since
there is no adjacent node from G it
stops there and we have the Q output
here that is a b c d e f and g so this
is how the breadth first search
algorithm works now to understand this
in a practical way let us try to execute
a program in Dev C plus plus
so now we are on dev C plus plus and the
program on my screen is an example for
BFS algorithm in this program we have a
queue first as BFS is executed using Q
data structure
and there are two variables that is rear
and front and there is one array named
as size and the size is defined here as
50.
next we created some functions first
there is a queue function to create a
queue then we have NQ and DQ to insert
and delete the element from the queue
so this is the NQ function and this is
the DQ function to insert and delete the
elements from the queue
then we have a function to display and
after that we have the empty function to
check whether a queue is empty or not
so this particular code segment is to
check whether the queue is empty or not
and this particular function is the
print function which is used to print
the elements inside the queue
after that we defined node and made a
function as creating a node and in node
there is a one variable named as vertex
and one pointer next to it
so this is the structure for creating
the node
and followed by the node we have created
another structure called graph and
inside graph we have the create graph
function to create the graphs and we
have number of vertices adjacent lists
and visited
and next we have the add edge where we
will add edges in between the vertices
and finally we have the BFS algorithm
so here we will check if the queue is
empty or not first then we will call the
DQ function and we will execute the BFS
algorithm
and now finally we have the main
function where we will add all the edges
to the graph and call the PFS algorithm
now let's try to run this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the output is
displayed on the screen
foreign
and then Q contains values two and one
now the node is visited to 2 followed by
that the queue has values 1 and 4 and
node has visited one and then Q contains
values 4 and 3 and node has visited the
value or Vertex 4 and finally Q contains
value 3 and the queue is reset and the
node is currently visited at node number
3.
now with that let's move ahead into the
next type of algorithm that is the depth
first search algorithm so what is depth
first search algorithm
so DFS algorithm is used for traversing
trees using the depth wise Direction
the execution of this algorithm begins
with the root node and explores each
branch before backtracking next DFS uses
stack data structure to remember to get
subsequent vertex and start a search
whenever a dead node appears or the dead
end appears at any iteration
now we used to have queues in BFS
algorithm but in DFS algorithm we will
be using Stacks now to understand the
working of depth first search let's go a
bit more detail
so here we have a graph so how depth
first search algorithm works now here we
can choose the root nodes first so once
the root node is chosen it sees the
possibilities of traversal it starts
from the left side tree first it first
visits B and now it will not stop at p
in VFS it used to stop at B and used to
check all the possibilities but here it
is not like that it will first visit P
then it will not stop at B it directly
sees the depth of the B that is it has
another child node so it will enter the
left child node and checks D and now
here it will not stop at D it will check
for possibilities ID so since there are
no possibilities from the left or right
side of D it will get back to B and now
it will check for another possibility
from P that is right side first it
finishes the left subtree on completion
of left subtree only then it will enter
the right subtree so here it checks for
the possibility it found e and from E it
will check for another depth search so
there is no depth search from E and not
on left and not on right so it comes
backs to p from B it visits the root
node again from here it checks for the
right subtrain now here we have C so it
will not stop at C it will go to the
next subtree that is f
and now it will not stop at F it will
search for other opportunities now since
there is no other opportunity or other
vertex from f it gets packs to C and
after that it checks for next right
subtree and that is g so from G it looks
for another opportunity or vertex since
there is no other vertex it gets back to
C then to a so to keep the traversal in
order
it uses stack data structure now for a
better understanding let us go through a
practical demo on dev C plus plus and
now we are on dev C plus plus and this
particular code is an example for DFS
algorithm in this particular code we
have defined the structure that is node
and inside the node structure we have
this vertex and node reference which
points to the next node in the graph
followed by that we have the graph
structure and inside graph structure we
have the number of vertices and visited
and reference to each node followed by
that we have the depth first search
algorithm and this particular code
segment is the Logic for depth first
search algorithm then we have the
structure of node reference and followed
by that we have the structure of graph
reference that is the number of vertices
visited and the adjacent vertex list and
then the reference of that particular
node is visited or not now we are using
dynamic memory allocation in here and
followed by that we have add edge
function where we will add edges between
the vertices and followed by that we
have the print graph function so here we
will be printing the stack data
structure which has the vertex after
visiting all the vertices in the graph
and finally we have our main function
where we will assign the edges to the
graph then we will call the depth first
search algorithm now let's try to
execute this code and see the output
there you go you can see that the code
got successfully executed and we have
our list here that is we have visited
the vertex 2 3 1 and 0.
now followed by this let us look into
the differences between breadth first
search and depth first search algorithms
so some of the fundamental differences
are breadth first search finds the
shortest path to the destination whereas
depth first search goes to the bottom of
the subtree and then backtracks
the next difference is BFS algorithm
uses a queue to keep track of the
following locations to visit whereas DFS
algorithm uses stack now we have gone
through that in the examples for both
DFS and BFS
followed by that the next difference is
the BFS uses fifo that is first in first
out order of implementation because we
are using queue data structure here
whereas DFS uses lost in first out order
of implementation because we are using
stack data structure the next difference
is BFS requires more memory as compared
to BFS and depth first search requires
less memory compared to that of BFS
followed by that we have BFS algorithm
which gives the shallowest path to the
solution next compared to BFS DFS
algorithm does not guarantee for
shallowest path as the solution
the next difference is in BFS algorithm
if you do not find any goal then you may
need to expand to the other nodes before
the solution is found whereas in DFS if
you do not find any goals then the
backtracking will start from the leaf
node now we will discuss some of the
major applications of BFS algorithms
so BFS algorithm can be easily used to
create the shortest path and the minimum
spanning tree to visit the graph
vertices in the shortest time possibly
with high accuracy
BFS algorithm is implemented to locate
all the neighboring nodes in
peer-to-peer Network and this will find
the required data faster
search engine or web crawlers can
quickly build multiple levels of indexes
by employing VFS algorithm and start
implementing from the source and then it
visits all the links from the source
the VFS algorithm guides the broadcast
packet to find and reach all the node it
has for the address now we will look
into the applications of DFS
the next application of DFS is it is
primarily used for scheduling jobs for
the given dependencies among the group
of jobs in computer science it is used
for instruction scheduling data
serialization and compilation task
ordering
next the DFS algorithm can be easily
adapted to search all solutions to a
maze including nodes in an existing path
in the visited set the breadth first
search approach repeats the procedure
for all the nodes until the desired node
is found
the queue data structure is the data
structure that is used for breadth first
search algorithm
for a better understanding we'll look at
an example of breadth first search
algorithm the blue color indicates that
the node has been already explored while
the pink color indicates that the node
has not been explored yet or visited yet
next we'll have our output
we will use a q data structure to keep
track of all the nodes visited and all
the nodes that are unvisited
so to begin let's look at the algorithm
as a result we'll have node a which is
added to the output and marked as
visited we must verify all the unvisited
adjacent nodes of a that is node B and
node C and add B and C nodes to the
output and NQ to the queue according to
the breadth first search algorithm
then we'll look at any node between V
and C we'll start with node B node D is
unvisited adjacent to node B so we'll
add node D to the output and queue and
since node B is now being visited we'll
DQ it
when it goes to node B the next
unvisited note is node e add node e to
the output and NQ to the DQ once node D
has completed its traversal DQ from the
queue
now in the case of node e the adjacent
node is node C which is already visited
thus we will dequeue node C from the
queue now that the pointer is pointing
to node C and node f is the next
unvisited node after the node C we will
set node F to output and queue here the
pointer leads to node F which has no
unvisited adjacent nodes so we will DQ F
from the queue and queue is empty so
we'll come to the hold here here's what
we got that is a b c d e and f after
understanding all the theoretical
aspects of BFS algorithm let's look at
the code of BFS algorithm and C
programming language
now we are on the Practical mode on my
screen you can see an example for BFS
algorithm we have declared a two
dimensional array with maximum row and
column size of 10 and 2 arrays the first
one is a square of a maximum size of 10
and second one which is a visited that
stores the maximum size of 10 as well
some variables nij and finally we
declared front which is initialized with
zero and rare variables which is
initialized with -1
we perform a loop from index 1 to the
size of an array visited in this
function with the condition that if two
dimensional array of column 1 and
visited array of index is not one we
initialize variable I to the front of
the queue then one is set as the front
of the Q index of the visited array and
we use the breadth first search function
with the vertex as the front of the
queue until front is less than or equal
to real then we enter the main function
where we Define the variable X that
stores the graph's vertex and then we
use the printf function to enter the
number of vertex that will be stored in
variable n then we perform loop from
index 1 to Q size and visited array in
which we initialize 0 to the queue and
index 1 to the visited array then after
that we'll enter the graph value in the
form of Matrix of two dimensional array
by performing the loop with two
variables I for the graph rho and J for
the graph F column then we print the
source node which is saved in the
variable X then we print the source node
which is saved in the variable X and we
call the breadth first search function
or method which takes a Vertex X as
parameter and V print which nodes are
reachable by looping from index 1 to the
size of the visited array if index 1 of
the array is visited otherwise breadth
first search is not possible so this was
the explanation of the program now let's
try to execute and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully compiled and now it's
asking for the input now it is asking
for the number of vertices let's enter
the number of vertices as 3
. now it is asking for us to enter the
input in the form of Matrix so the first
row will be 1
and 3. so these are the first rows the
next rows will be 2 3 and 4. so the last
row elements are 3 4 and 5. so we have
successfully given all the three rows of
elements now let us select the source
node so the source node would be 2. now
all the nodes that are reachable from
the source node 2 are 1 2 and 3. so
there you go that's how you implement
the BET first search algorithm so what
is a depth first search
so basically a depth first search is an
algorithm for traversing or searching
the tree or graph data structures they
algorithm starts at the root node
selecting some arbitrary node as the
root node in case of graph and X Plus as
far as possible along each branch before
backtracking
yeah so DFS starts with the initial node
of the graph then goes deeper until it
finds the goal nodes over the leaf nodes
or the nodes that have no children that
is the end part here you can see 4 and 7
are the leaf nodes so the depth first
search algorithm runs till the end of
all the nodes that is a 10 all these are
the leaf nodes are the last gold nodes
ndfs the backtracking starts once all
the nodes are explored and the DFS
algorithm uses stack data structure for
its traversal now that was a brief
introduction to the DFS algorithm now
for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so here we have a graph data structure
with elements A B C D E and F so we will
be running the DFS algorithm and we will
be traversing through all the nodes of
this particular graph and the traversal
will be recorded using a stack data
structure and we have two different
colors which will be used to indicate
the elements color
so the black color is for the nodes
which are not visited yet and the blue
color will indicate the nodes which are
being traversed already
now this is the stack data structure
that we will be using for the traversal
and we have another part which declares
or which gives out the output of the
traversal of the nodes of this
particular graph
now we will begin with the first one
that is a now followed by that we will
move ahead to B then after B we will go
through d
then after T we have e next we have C
and last we have f
so that's how we travels through the
graph using the DFS algorithm now for a
little more understanding let's go
through a practical example where we
will be executing a program for
implementing the DFS algorithm
so this particular program on my screen
is an example for DFS algorithm so here
we have the structure node so followed
by that we have also the methods which
will create the edge
and which will also print the graph
elements and finally we have the main
class now don't worry about the code
this particular code segment or the
complete code document will be added in
the description box below and you can
have access to it and try to run it on
your local system and have a better
learning experience now without further
Ado let's try to run this program and
get the output and see how the DFS
algorithm gets implemented and traverses
through the graph
there you go the program got
successfully executed and we had the
graph elements that is 0 1 and 2 and 3
so it has visited all the elements that
is 2 3 1 and 0 according to the Stacked
data structure and we have found your
output over here in this session we will
discuss shell sort
shell sort is a sorting algorithm that
is based on insertion sort algorithm and
it is very efficient when the smaller
value is on the far right and must be
shifted to the far left then this method
avoids significant shifts as in
insertion sort
now let's discuss the algorithm of shell
salt
let's say we have an array we will
initialize a variable H this H will
represent intervals
then we will divide this array into H
intervals it will create some sub arrays
then we will apply insertion sort on
these sub arrays
after that we will reduce the interval
Latch by 1. then we will repeat this
process recursively until H counts down
to 1.
we have now introduced shell sort and
its algorithm now let's try to implement
this algorithm in the code reader
first we will start within function to
sort an array using shell sort
so and
cell sort
we will write argument as end
ARR
bracket
comma
and n
will start within big interval then we
will reduce this interval by 1. so
for Loop
and interval
equals to n by 2
.
interval
greater than zero
and interval
divide equals to 2.
now we will do a gap insertion sort for
this interval
so for
and I is equals to interval
I is less than n
I plus equals to 1.
and
them is equals to
ARR packet I
now we will shift earlier Gap sorted
element up until the correct location
for arri I is for
so int
a
so for
a is equals to I
and J greater than equals to interval
and then
ARR bracket
J minus interval
greater than temp
and J minus equals to
interval
now ARR
at G
is equals to ARR
J minus
interval
now we will put the stamp in its correct
location so ARR
bracket J
is equals to temp
now I will return 0.
now let's write a function to print this
array
so avoid
print
array
and error
comma and n
so for Loop
and J is equals to 0
a less than n
J plus plus
C out
ARR
bracket J
now we will write the function for the
main block
so end
ARR
is equals to
12 comma 34 comma 56 comma
85 comma
2 comma
9.
comma 11.
comma
five
now let's find the size for this array
so int n is equals to
size of
array
divided by
size of
first element of this array
now
see out
array
before
sub print
array
ARR comma
and
cell sort
ARR
comma n
now C out
arrays
after
sorting
we will again print array
comma m
m
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array here we will look into
the real life example of greedy
algorithm in order to understand it
better this is Alex he's quite wealthy
and intelligent as he works for one of
the most reputed I.T firms and this is
Alex's best friend Rachel Rachel is in
dire need of 85 dollars right now
however she needs money in such a
quantity that the number of coins is
kept to a minimum so Rachel shared this
issue with Alex and asked him for help
now Alex is thinking about Rachel's
issue which he can easily fix because he
has a limitless supply of 50 dollars
twenty dollars ten dollars and five
dollar coins stashed in various bags
although this being said Alex needed to
think about the constrained Rachel told
him about he needed to give her money
such that the number of coins utilized
must be minimal to do so Alex began
making a list of the various coin
combinations in which he could present
money to Rachel however after a while he
became confused due to the vast number
of conceivable combinations
so he decided to use his programming
ability to solve real life problems
Alex developed a program that will
provide him with the optimal number of
coins that he can present to Rachel
this generated program was iterating
through the different possibilities to
choose the best solution
at each iteration the program added the
coin of the largest value that was not
taking Alex passed the amount to be paid
which is 85 dollars in this case
for 85 dollars the largest denomination
ID can start giving is 50 now ID is
still short of 35 dollars to reach the
amount so that the next largest coin
program can take in as 20 dollars
but since the program still requires 15
dollars to meet the threshold the next
highest denomination it can accept is
ten dollars followed by five dollars
the best part about this program was
that it allowed Alex to present 85
dollars in just four coins which is
fairly incredible
the vital thing to note here is that
after each Loop the program makes a
greedy Choice providing the coin with
the highest potential value what I mean
here by greedy is that locally optimal
choice is picked at every step to reach
the global Optimum solution now moving
ahead we will formulate the idea of
greedy algorithms
basically a greedy algorithm is based on
a problem-solving method that involves
making locally optimal decisions at each
stage in the hopes of achieving a global
Optimum that means at each stage we
choose a locally optimal value in the
hopes of arriving at the optimum
possible end result
furthermore this algorithm is an
optimization technique that can find
either minimum Optimum result or maximum
Optimum result
the best part about this algorithm is
that it is simple to understand and
Implement as well Additionally the
runtime complexity for this algorithm is
pretty reasonable
however the fundamental disadvantage of
this strategy is that we only receive
the globally Optimum value in a small
percentage of cases
having said that you must be thinking
about when to implement this algorithm
for solving particular problems as it
does not always produce globally Optimum
results
well let me tell you guys that we have
two conditions to judge our problem for
implementing greedy algorithms
the first condition is the greedy Choice
property this notion states that making
locally optimal judgments can lead to
the global Optimum solution for a given
problem
the second condition is about optimal
substructure
the problem has an optimal substructure
only if an optimal solution to the
entire problem comprises the Optimal
Solutions to the sub problems
in simpler words that means the problem
can be split down into multiple sub
problems and the solutions to these sub
problems can collectively lead to a
solution for the entire problem
if both the above mentioned properties
are satisfied by the problem then we can
create a greedy solution for that
particular problem
moving forward we will look into the
steps for constructing a greedy solution
finding the substructure or subproblem
that can lead us to the final answer is
the first step in building a greedy
algorithm
because in this algorithm we are just
trying to operate with local Optima to
reach the global Optimum solution
the second step is about determining the
type of solution the given problem can
result in two that can be either the
largest sum or minimum path
the final step for creating the greedy
solution is about creating an iterative
process for traversing through local
stages and making decisions to reach a
globally Optimum solution now you might
be confused about how we can do that
well let's go through an example to
understand the approach to implement a
greedy solution
the example that we are going to deal
with is called the traveling salesman
problem in which a Salesman is supposed
to reach the destination from a given
current location
the representation of cities and parts
connecting them is done using graph
structure that each node is considered
as a city and edges connecting them as
paths having Edge weight as the distance
between the two cities
now in this case we are supposed to find
the minimum path between two cities so
to do that we will begin from the
current arbitrary position from this
node called as starting location there
are three possible paths but the path
towards City B has less distance hence
we will Traverse this Edge primarily as
it is an optimal local route
we have reached City B now and from this
note we have two possible paths out of
which one part directly leads us towards
the destination city having distance 20
but the other path leading towards the
city F has Edge weight value or distance
value as 2.
hence according to the local optimal
decision we will choose the edge
connecting cities B and F for traversal
we have reached the city F now from this
Nora City there is only one path leading
us to our destination
hence we will Traverse it now we have
reached the destination city the path
highlighted in the green shade is the
global Optimum for this DSP problem you
can verify that by calculating the edge
weights for all other possible parts
since the solution allows us to reach
the global Optimum by making optimal
decisions at the local stage this
strategy to solve the problem will be
considered a greedy approach
now moving ahead we will look into the
demerits of using greedy algorithm
we have learned that the greedy
algorithm makes decisions based on local
Optimum instead of analyzing the broader
picture of the whole data hence there is
a possibility that the greedy solution
might not be the best optimal solution
for some problems
for example consider this traveling
salesman problem in this problem the
highlighted part is a created solution
to reach the destination city from the
current location using a greedy
algorithm
But If You observe this graph the
selected solution is not the global
optimal solution for this problem in
contrast it is the worst generated
solution to reach the destination
that is why the greedy algorithm is
considered to be prone to correctness
issues even if the algorithm is correct
proving why it is correct is difficult
thus it is deemed to be trickier to
solve specific issues
now we will discuss about applications
of 3D algorithms to understand their
importance
the first application of a greedy
algorithm is its use for constructing
minimum spanning trees the coding
approaches that we use to generate MSDS
is based on the greedy algorithm both
prim's algorithm and Crystal's algorithm
are known as greedy algorithms as they
make decisions based on locally optimal
decisions
the next application of the greedy
algorithm is its use to implement
Huffman encoding and decoding algorithms
the Huffman coding technique is a
lossless data compression method
the concept is to give variable length
codes to input characters the lengths of
which are determined by the frequency of
the related characters
the smallest code is assigned to the
most frequently occurring character
whereas the largest chord is assigned to
the least frequently occurring character
this process is carried out by making
local Optimum decisions hence it is also
considered to be a greedy algorithm
final application of the greedy
algorithm is its use for developing
solutions to well-known coding problems
those problems are the activity
selection problem job selection problem
and fractional knapsack problem all
these problems generate solutions by
making decisions at each local stage so
the solutions for these problems can be
developed quite easily using the greedy
approach
the prims algorithm is used to find
minimum spanning tree for a given graph
but what exactly is a minimum spanning
tree or MSD well a minimum spanning tree
is a subset of graph G having the same
number of vertices as of graph G and
edges equivalent to a number of vertices
-1 along with these properties it also
has a minimum cost for summation of all
age weights included in a spanning tree
algorithm starts with a single node and
explores all the adjacent nodes at every
step the edges with minimal age weights
causing no Cycles in the graph gets
selected hence we can say that prim's
algorithm makes a locally optimal Choice
intending to find global optimal choice
that is why it is called as greedy
algorithm
moving ahead let's understand how we can
find out the minimum spanning tree using
prim's algorithm
now given a graph G consisting of vertex
is V and edges e we need to construct a
minimum spanning tree g Dash with
vertices V Dash equal to V and ages e
Dash equal to V minus 1. having this
summation of edge vets minimal this
particular graph G contains 9 vertices
and 12 edges that means her MST G Dash
will have 9 vertices and 9 minus 1 edges
that is 8 edges so with this in mind
let's create an MST for this graph G
using prim's algorithm
the first step in prim's algorithm is to
choose an arbitrary starting vertex here
we'll select node a as our starting
vertex
now the next step in primps algorithm is
to add new vertices with a minimum age
weight in this case from vertex a we
have two possible edges for traversal
the age weight for h a b is 1 whereas
the age weight for age AC is six so
obviously we'll choose vertex B here
since we have reached vertex B we will
look into the possible edges for adding
an age with minimum weight to our MSD
hbd has the minimum age weight so we'll
add it to our MSD
now from vertex D there is only one Edge
hence we'll directly add that h d h into
a spanning tree
now from vertex Edge there are two
possible paths out of which the path h i
has minimum cost thus will add it to our
MSD from vertex I there is only one Edge
so we'll directly include it in our MST
now that I have included vertex G I am
going to check for connected edges I
have from vertex G but since there is
only one Edge from vertex G we'll just
insert it on rmsd from vertex e two
edges are going to different vertices so
we will choose the one with least age
weight and that age is h e c
now that I have included node C I am
going to examine what connected edges I
have to consider from vertex C
currently out of these two highlighted
edges I want to pick that edge which has
not yet been included in MSD and has the
minimum age weight but the question that
arises here is can I add this Edge AC
into our MSD
well we cannot if we add H AC to our MST
then it won't remain a tree structure
due to the creation of cycle or a loop
which we cannot allow to happen
according to the prem's algorithm thus
in this particular case we'll choose
Edge CF for insertion in our MSD and
finally the summation of age weight for
this MST will become 30. also till the
time you must have observed that this
algorithm chooses the next vertex that
offers the most prominent or immediate
benefit it started with an empty
spanning tree for maintaining two sets
of vertices the first set was for the
vertices included in the MSD and the
other one was for the vertices that
haven't been included in the MSD at
every step this algorithm considered all
the edges that connected the two sets
and picked the one with minimum age
weight from The adjacency Matrix a group
of Ages that connects two sets of
vertices in a graph is called cut in
graph Theory so at every step of primps
algorithm we find a cut of two sets one
contains the vertices already included
in MST and the other containing this
rest of vertices after that we pick the
minimum age weight from the cut and
include that vertex to our MSD set that
is why this algorithm is called as
greedy algorithm having said that let's
dive into the implementation strategy
for developing code for prim's algorithm
the idea behind prim's algorithm is
simple all the vertices of a spanning
tree must be connected hence the two
disjoint subsets of vertices must be
connected in order to create a spanning
tree and further this vertices should
only be associated with the minimum age
weight to make it a minimum spanning
Tree in order to store these vertices
and edges we'll create an adjacency
Matrix using 2D array in C programming
language well the indexes of this 2D
Matrix will be the vertices where the
values other than 0 will be the edge
widths for indexes 0 1 and 2 you can
clearly see that the adjacency Matrix is
having value 0 that means there is no
recurring connection or Loop for these
vertices so primarily let's add them to
our graph structure
for age 1 to 2 we have the weight value
2 so we'll add age between vertex 0 and
1.
after that
we have age between 2 and 1. the value
for this age weight is 3 so we'll add
age between 1 and 2 and assign 3 as its
Edge way
finally the age weight for connecting 0
to 2 is 4 so we'll insert it in our
graph as well in the next slide we'll
discuss the strategy for implementation
of a prim's algorithm
from this example I hope you are clear
with how we are going to maintain a
structure of a graph using 2D Matrix in
the next slide we'll discuss the
strategy for the implementation of
prim's algorithm
the first step of this algorithm is to
maintain a set for keeping track of
vertices included in an MSD once we
create the set we'll assign a key value
to all vertices in the input graph
initially we are going to set all key
values as infinite and at the runtime
we'll assign that 0 to the first vertex
by doing that we choose it as an
arbitrary starting vertex once done with
that we'll start adding vertices to our
minimum spanning tree for that we'll
pick up a Vertex U with minimum weight
to insert it into our set after that
we'll also update the key values for all
adjacent vertices of you
on that note let's visit a code Editor
to implement prim's algorithm using C
programming language
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now in order to begin with coding
implementation we'll need to load some
dependencies for this implementation
process we are going to need a Boolean
set in order to keep track of vertices
included in other MSD that is why we'll
include a standard Boolean library in
our program
so hash include
STD
dot h
once done with this addition we'll
Define a number of vertices that we are
going to use in our graph I am going to
set the number of vertices to 5. so
let's do that
hash
Define
vertices
5.
and if you want to implement MSD for a
larger graph then you must set the
number of vertices to a more significant
number now let's move to the main
function the graph that I am going to
use for generating a minimum spanning
tree is supposed to be stored inside a
2d Matrix
so first let's have a look at that graph
this is the graph for which we want to
develop a minimum spanning tree the
first step that we must take to do that
is converting this graph into 2D Matrix
as discussed earlier the diagonal values
will be null or zero and other values
will be the age weights between two
nodes so without wasting any time on
this I will directly create adjacency
Matrix for this graph inside our code
editor this part is what maintaining our
graph in form of 2D Matrix now after
this
we are calling Prime semestick function
which is responsible for generating a
minimum spanning tree so let's do that
here
rims underscore MST and we'll pass this
graph
to this function
but we haven't developed any code for
this premium SD function but we'll do
that now
so let's create prim's MSD function void
Prince underscore MSD
and will pass graph as an argument
should be vertices
and vertices to make it a 2d Matrix
now inside this function we'll create an
array name key to store Key values of
all vertices
and key
vertices
along with it we'll also initialize the
parent in which we'll store our actual
MST and Boolean set to keep track of
each and every vertex of our graph so
let's create that parent
array
vertices
thank you
and we'll create Boolean
set for maintaining track of all
vertices
now after this what we'll do is we'll
set the key values of all vertices to
infinity and will also make sure that
these vertices are not part of our
minimum spanning preset so for that
we'll create a for Loop and inside this
for Loop we'll use iterator element I
and will initialize this element to zero
till
vertices
and will increase the iterator element I
for each Loop
and set this Loop
we will set key I
to the possible integer maximum value
and in order to use this value we'll
need to add one Library which is called
as limits.h so we'll add it here
hash
include
limits
dot h
okay
after this
we will also make sure that these
vertices are not part of our minimum
spanning tree set or Boolean set so for
that we'll write statement mean
underscore span underscore tree
I
should be false that means empty
and we'll add indentation
okay
now in order to choose the arbitrary
index we'll set the key value of our
first vertex to zero so that it will be
chosen first in our minimum spanning
tree for that we'll write statement key
0 should be equal to
zero
and as we have chosen vertex 0 as our
first arbitrary vertex so we'll also set
the index 0 of the parent array to -1
by doing this we are ensuring that the
index 0 is the root node of our minimum
spanning tree now to choose vertices
with the minimal key value we'll create
a new function named list key so let's
do that
end
and list
underscore key
and inside it will pass arguments in key
Boolean set
and inside this function body we are
going to set all key values to Infinity
so let's do that in list
will be equal to int underscore Max
and will also initialize
minimum underscore index as new variable
Now using a for Loop will Traverse
through all vertices if the given vertex
is not present inside the minimum
spanning tree set and the key value is
also smaller than the least value then
we'll set the least variable to the key
value and minimum index to that
particular index V so let's create that
for Loop
and inside it end v as iterator element
and we'll initialize it to Value 0
and the maximum limit for this V will be
vertices
and
will increase the value of this small V
variable
plus plus
now if the chosen vertex is not present
inside minimum spanning tree set
and and
the key value
for that vertex
is also smaller than list
then
we will set least
equal to
key of
V
and minimum index
yeah
two three
and we'll get out of this for Loop and
will return
the minimum index value
on that note let's arrive back at our
Prime semestick function
here using a for Loop will fetch the
minimum index that we have generated
inside a list key function
so let's create for Loop
we'll use count variable here
and we'll initialize it to zero
and we'll move this count variable
till vertices
minus 1.
which is nothing but the number of
vertices in our minimum spanning tree
next we'll increase this count variable
now we have arrived inside this for Loop
body
now we'll store that phage minimum index
value in variable U so in u
will be equal to least
underscore key
and will pass
keep
and
Boolean set that is mean underscore span
underscore tree
and
we will include this list node that is U
to our minimum spanning preset
or Boolean set
equal to true
now here we'll use a nested Loop in
order to insert a complete Edge which is
initiating from node 0. inside this Loop
we'll further call if log to validate
some conditions so let's create that
nested for Loop first
foreign
and we'll check graph
U
to V
and and
mean
span tree
V
is equal to equal to false
and and
graph
U
three
it's minimum than K of V
then what we'll do is
we'll set parent
of V
2 U
and key
of V
to graph
u v
so now you must be thinking about what
exactly is this code is doing so
actually what we are doing is we are
inserting node U into our minimum
spanning tree and once we include node U
into our minimum spanning tree then we
check if there is any age between u and
v v is nothing but all the vertices
inside the graph if there is age with
between u and v then we check if that V
is included in our spanning tree or not
if it is not included then we check the
value key value of V
if the key value of V is greater then
what we do is we set parent of V is
equal to U and key value of V is equal
to graph u v which is nothing but the
weight between h u and v
so that's what this code is doing
after this what we'll do is we'll write
one printf statement so for that we'll
need to get out of this for Loop and
we'll write printf statement print f
created
spanning
tree
for given graph
as
backslash n
so that this next part comes inside the
next line
and
will also
make a call to
print underscore
MSD
function which is not created it but
will write code for it once done with
this call and will pass parent and graph
to it
well
now let's
create a code for this print frame
semester function
and
print
underscore frames
MST
and will pass
and
parent
will pass end graph
with vertices
and
vertices
now inside this function
what we'll do is we'll write one printf
statement
to
show the pattern of printing
Edge
foreign
weight
slash and
semicolon and then next slide
will create iterator element
and will initialize it to 1
and we'll extend this till
vertices
and I plus plus
printf
printers
modulus d
Ash
slash
d
backslash d
modulus d
and backslash n
and will pass
a parent
I
comma I
comma
graph
I
and parent
of I
this statement will print a graph on our
screen
but here is one mistake
that I have made I haven't added the
indentation for this for Loop
okay
I think this should be fine now
we can say that our coding
implementation is finish now let's run
our code and check if it is working or
not
when we have received output on our
console here that means a code is bug
free and it works fine you can verify
this result by drawing the spanning tree
of output on your notebook and further
you can compare it with the graph that
we have shown previously
furthermore if you are concerned about
this code then don't be as we can send
it over to you if you drop your email
IDs in the comment section below
Additionally you can also try to run it
on your local system to understand its
minute implementation details and
implications
so with this successful coding
implementation we came to the end of
this video
and with that we have reached the end of
day two so far we have learned the data
structures and algorithms on day three
of software development learning we'll
escalate things and get started with the
whole programming language and learn the
object-oriented programming Concepts our
programming language of choice would be
C plus plus thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe to stay tuned
for more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here